welcome to the second annual trashtades
awards
[Applause]
[Music]
mommy
[Music]
before we get criticism we have to undo
our jackets because we're sitting down
because someone got really angry last
year i just wanted to show off the suit
let's do it let's do a drip appreciation
real quick yeah unlike last year i
actually am wearing a jojo suit oh joe
you actually wore pants this time i wore
pants this time all right no one will
ever know i didn't wear pants last time
with a black shirt this time mixing it
up feeling spicy all right
wait i i'm because i've never worn a
double-breasted suit normally yeah do
you still unbutton it or it's
appropriate to button your double
breasted yeah yeah yeah i thought i
thought okay so connor and i will just
do it i'll keep i'll keep it back all
right all right whatever whatever
i went with the mr thai this time i'm
going to change
it nice nice good looking good well
let's try the champagne there yeah yeah
before we i guess jerk ourselves off and
yeah
for the
that's no different from what we
normally do but uh ladies and gentlemen
this is episode 100 yes we've hit the
big three digits
102 years of trash taste
102 years i haven't had this much head
since i went to a jojo meetup bro
oh my god it's like back at the walmart
it isn't a [ __ ] beer
it's champagne okay it is meant to be
bubbling champagne
by the way wendy thank you for the
glasses thank you very much for the
glasses well cheers boys boys to 100
episodes 100 episodes
[Applause]
wow we are
literally in triple digit episodes my
god that's scary that's gone so quickly
do you know what i forgot about
i forgot that we moved to a new studio
this year yeah yeah
this year huh happened this year well i
was like within the like
show was it the last episode yeah yeah
last year yeah and we only had like four
or five episodes after the trash chase
awards
before the move yeah that's right it
wasn't long after wasn't it yeah yeah
but it didn't feel that way because the
last episode we filmed in the studio old
studio was the trash chase awards right
i believe so i probably
i think because we tried to delay it as
much as possible to have the awards as
close to episode 50 as possible even
though we'd already secured our new
studio and we needed to record a bunch
in uh
uh we've got a bunch of episodes to
uh make sure that we had enough episodes
to cover us for the move yeah yeah yeah
the trash days episode was the last
episode yeah that's yeah yeah yeah
so how did you boys feel about uh i have
you ever been on the podcast that made
it past like 50 episodes
no i've never been on anything that made
it have you ever been on a podcast
before period
my own podcast that lasted two episodes
i had i had my own radio show that
lasted
the
anime show yeah
i think i did like 30 episodes of that
how many episodes of portal
did that and you got like 20 or 14
something no i don't know it was it was
weird i was more than 20. it was way
more your
yeah yeah yeah you don't get another
chance to start again
you're the only one who can defeat me
yeah exactly right exactly how many how
many episodes you probably got to like
oh maybe like little under 50. maybe
because the thing is there was like two
versions i was like poor taku and
jaetaku so it was it was like that went
on
foreign law that went on for like four
years though but it was four years not
as consistent as trash taste so it is a
very very different vibe i think yes
actually you have 76 videos i don't know
if that's 76. that's 76 episodes then
we've we've already beaten hey
[Music]
new pb new pb i think to be honest it's
a miracle that like a podcast even lasts
over 100 episodes true i feel like i
feel like i feel like over 50 episodes
like oh yeah honestly it's pretty
impressive that we have uploaded every
single week we've never missed a week
you've never missed an episode we've
never had to delay it a day please don't
let that be poorly you know you know you
know you know
because like most most other podcasts
they go on for like an hour per episode
yeah we've done two hour episodes bar
like i think two or something yeah 400
episodes that's two that's like roughly
200 hours of talking yeah too long too
long too long at which point do we make
as much content hours as one piece
that's that's that's the next goal that
is the next goal i want i wanted to get
to the point where there will be people
out there who will go what takes longer
to finish one piece
i mean we're getting there
yeah but like think about it a lot of a
lot has we've done a lot this year uh
because we've obviously moved studio uh
and i think trash tastes after dark has
just been like a massive thing that oh
yeah
i mean i remember last year we had like
three streams or something that we would
stream because we kind of felt like it i
think we did
four or five episodes of trash today
after dark but then obviously there
weren't so much like you know like like
a twitch show as more just like uh you
know a trash taste after birth you know
what type of thing or like
you know
after after you know
yeah you know
just like squeezing that last little bit
from like the main episode into like a
stream you know i think it's really cool
we have like a different set for the
live streams and the [ __ ] the the normal
podcast you know yeah and you know it
offers a different kind of trash tasting
experience yeah the old episode was just
the same one yes because like i think
the issue with the old trash taste
streams is that it was just more trash
taste it just looked like trash taste
yeah it was it looked like trash daisy
which we did the same things as we do on
trash taste we just talked uh just with
a live chat but i feel like there's
definitely uh we've definitely been able
to distinct uh make trash taste after
like more distinctive not only with the
set but with what we do on it as well
because we have we get to do like play
some fun games uh we get to do some fun
stuff
could you ever imagine trying to do the
24 hour stream in the old office oh my
god that would have sucked oh sure
actually would quit like yeah you told
us you know it's good because uh people
are starting to comment oh well i like
trash taste after dark more than trash
taste now so that means that we're doing
a good job yeah yeah
that's like that's like weedly
flattering yeah it is yeah to be like oh
we beat ourselves
i i mean like if you prefer trashley
soft dog that's like all good that's
still trash taste baby that's yeah
yeah still us so we're okay with it what
is the trash taste awards resource music
explain it to people who don't know what
the trash taste awards are it's
something that we've done once before
and we liked it so much that we're doing
it again yeah basically we're gonna try
and do it annually yeah basically you
know there's a lot of moments in trash
taste and not everyone can keep up with
there's a lot of a lot of content a lot
of arguments a lot of dumb [ __ ] that
happens maybe a screenshot you recognize
you're like where would you episode that
from yeah yeah so basically this is an
award show to kind of have you the
viewers vote on your favorite moments of
the last 50 episodes of trash taste yeah
most i guess iconic moments the dumbest
screenshots the baddest takes and uh
when we complain about america yeah so
basically it's basically just a
highlight reel uh for you guys because
there's a lot of trash taste content now
not only on one channel on multiple
channels so this is basically inside
joke the episode yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it's it's it's your it's your chance to
catch up to all of the weird and
wonderful moments you may have missed
over the years yeah yeah so if there's
like a moment you know you see during
the trash taste awards where you're like
oh i want to know what that's like you
know in context i want to see the full
scope of it then you can go back and
check it out and catch up on it and uh
for us we just get it to suck our own
dicks that's uh
jojo that's that's why we're wearing the
jojo suits right that is why we're
wearing the jokers yes yes we
this is literally like the obama image
with just like the medal right now
oh look at look at all these awards so
we have a bunch of categories we tell
everyone what the categories are yeah
just go through them all yeah do you
have a slide for that ashley or no no
i think we i do oh really did you have a
slideshow
brilliant actually
actually planned ahead for us
all right by the way it's spelt award
you that's an inside joke again i gotta
explain that because oh yeah yeah yeah
the last time i did the post calling for
ideas for the awards i didn't type i
read it yeah i did a typo so that's why
it has a w it's not that funny but it
kind of stuck around it's also because
we're giving ourselves a w yeah i guess
we are
i had to make it wrong
it was it was the kind of thing
you know one w in award wasn't enough i
needed another dog
joey if there's one thing trash chase is
not about it's not about getting w's
joey because none of us get w's it's
like two w's cancel each other yeah it's
all
about to find out on this award man i'm
gonna go to the first slide what's going
on with all the nominations tonight yeah
yeah so uh we have hot take of the year
that's number one we're just going out
the gate we're going straight on
you guys are in for a treat we're best
out of context clip screen grab of the
year most degenerate moment most salty
moment
monkey moment named after me i suppose
yes uh the best story the biggest clown
the biggest chad the best nickname the
best complaining about america moment of
course yes sorry americans sorry best
meme the fans they actually talked about
anime
that's a new one right that is a new one
yeah we didn't have that last year best
engine best drip laziest drip best rent
best argument worst food take best poop
moment i think that's new yeah yeah
that's the most privileged
moment of the year and the best trash
taste episode of the year according to
you guys yeah so you guys voted on this
and you guys gave us the nominations as
well so we might judge your taste yeah
yeah
so if you want to blame anyone you can
blame yourself so if we get to a certain
point you're like no no the best one was
definitely not in these nominations yeah
that's on you yeah
so i mean i mean like i wouldn't blame
you guys because there's a lot of
content that happened this past year and
even like we were making the content and
we don't remember hardly anything uh
happened this year it's gonna be like a
nice trip down like memory lane right
because i guarantee there's going to be
a bunch of moments with like oh that got
nominated yeah i i do remember i do
remember looking at the nominations list
and there was like one moment that i
remember happened that i think deserves
to be represented somewhere here so i'm
gonna just gonna shout it out now yeah
uh because it was actually at the old
studio which is why i think it got like
passed over
but it was the moment where the
confusion happened when conor was
talking about taking the fridge all from
my house yeah from your house and like i
that was the only moment i remember post
i was like oh damn if only i remembered
early i could have actually put it in
but like uh mood on you can play the
clip because i just want to give it a
quick shout out because it's one of my
favorites of the year finally getting
rid of my uh
my laundry machine uh washing machine
yeah we're getting rid of ourselves yeah
i got rid of my my cockroach-infested
one
oh you still have that one
yeah i still have that one okay okay
he cleaned it off
but you know i mean i don't know what's
what's been in there yeah yeah yeah it
is nice to get rid of it and get a new
one get something nice you can afford it
treatment i'm taking the old one from
this studio
are you
yeah
wait what are you actually yeah because
it's like the equal amounts of confusion
where connor says a story about taking
the fridge and we all think all three of
us thought three different things i
thought the right thing it's my story
because i
what the [ __ ] because because it was
like using like
using the scripts like that and it and
we were like saying oh you took it from
this place
yeah yeah and it was just like the
perfect like chaotic moment and i
remember like i remember like one of my
favorite pros was like the subreddit
breaking down how this yeah yeah and it
was like
it was like a jcs
criminal cycle yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and fails between yeah
unfortunately unfortunately uh it seems
many people forgot that because it was
actually at this point
you know you'll notice there's like
recency bias with some of these yeah we
don't know who's won yet we are totally
in the dark but we know the nominations
obviously
um so yeah it's going to be interesting
see how people chose yeah
yeah i mean i'm excited for it yeah yeah
we just uh jumped straight into it we
have a lot of stuff
not as hard as holding your mom though
okay you don't know that you don't know
that my mom is a beautiful woman how do
you
would you describe your
i believe we're going right out of the
gate with our hot take of the year
because here's here's the thing right i
don't know what counts as like a hot
take is it like a bad take or
controversial take
i think it's a bit of both you know yeah
if you have a take that 95 people
disagree with yeah that could get you in
the hot tape category yeah all right i
think if you're also it's just a bad
take right
you know i'm sure when uh uh whenever
they figured out the earth was flat i'm
sure that was a hot take at the time
actually it's a bad take just normally
you mean when they figured out that the
world around you is a hot take just not
a bad take with reasons
if you think about it listen that's all
that's all the hot taking people have
been shunned in the past and then they
turned out to be right so a hot take
doesn't mean you're right it just means
you're going against the consensus let's
see what the nominations are so yeah we
got 90 of bread tastes the same that's
uh that's a gauntlet okay i have to ask
do you stand by this statement to this
day um
what did i say in the episode
i can't remember the general sentiment
of this ta the take do you stand by it i
can't uh i don't believe all bread
tastes the same but ninety percent but
yes there's ten percent that tastes like
right so i because i believe okay here's
the thing i remember the argument we had
was because connor was saying i would
eat bread as a main course and i was
like i can't eat bread as a main course
i need a supplement with the bread
in order to enjoy it right it's a nice
snack but it's like not a meal you know
um and that's where that's where i
let out this outrageous line and another
food take here from conor this time food
poisoning is not an illness do you stand
by that absolutely i think it was a case
of i think it was a case of
good art good point terrible execution
on my part which is connor syndrome at
this point yeah that's just like an
actual like valid take that i just
described so poorly that people don't
want to agree with right and then on the
subreddit and twitter and stuff people
have to fix my explanation oh yeah so
that that often i mean they have to fix
the explanation with all those i still
stand by this this general sentiment is
still you know okay and then uh one from
me this time jesus kaisen was okay it's
really that outrageous
i mean i don't think it was but i hope
this one wins
i really really want to just say
someone's okay to win of the year kind
of agrees
like out of everything here is like we
have some outrageous takes but like i
want that one to wait just because
just to be like shonen fans be like
partake of the year 90 percent of what
is all the same this is not the only
time when shown in fans are actually
going to come together to like cooperate
on something i really hope so don't stop
right there because the next one is 86
was bad by me
i stand by that obviously some of them
are animated
this was the one of the biggest
meltdowns i'd ever seen from a trash
taste episode people lost their [ __ ]
when i said this yeah they all were in
like in tears it reminded me that our
trash taste episode uh our trash tastes
viewers were also anime fans which i
forgot for the longest time yeah i i
forgot for the longest time
like like us people here watched anime
at one point in their lives you know and
uh they're very passionate about what i
hate about when i have a take about
anime i'm sure you guys can relate to
this is that no matter what how much i
watch or what i say there's always some
justification as to why i'm wrong i feel
like it's not just anime it's just
whenever you watch something in general
yeah like like you and like doctor
strange
you you're like
what do you mean you you haven't paid 15
for a disney plus subscription and watch
nine hours worth of sub content and i'm
sorry that you don't understand doctor
strange too after watching only doctor
strange one it's like what's wrong with
you marvel fans okay uh i'm sure that'll
be in the next year's awards yeah but
yeah this was one where i said i watched
nine episodes and apparently that wasn't
enough to form an opinion apparently no
of course um so i stand by my table 86
it's like judging one piece and stopping
at episode 100 you know like how how
that is
after all the times you hear it gets
good at episode 800. yeah you did it you
did it you didn't listen to them
you guys can enjoy the shows i just
don't enjoy it that's it get over it all
right dan who won this who won this one
all right please jesus christ and win i
just wanted and the winner they better
be bread it better be [ __ ] take of
the year goes to
90 of bread it tastes the same
[Applause]
you know what iron man goddammit iron
man
yes anime takes a valley thank you
are you saying that you think that
jiu-jitsu tyson is just okay guys i'm
just okay absolutely okay absolutely the
most outrageous take of all
right let's let's find out actually
because what statistics
statistics do you want to know how many
percent uh how much percentage of the
vote your hot take got i want to guess
that he got like 60 to 70 of the vote
yeah well he got 66.9 percent of the
vote so
apparently a lot of people thought his
take was back
why all of europe came together no no
the entire german population joined in
to vote
what are the rest uh in second place was
you conor with food poisoning is not an
illness with twenty twenty point four
percent of the vote wow barely any for
the other animated yeah what were the
other ones uh jiu jitsu was okay came in
third with seven point six percent of
the vote oh and uh connor's second take
was the last with five point one see
everyone only five percent of people
agree with everyone agrees with us
objection
yeah just because one one means that the
others are right right that's that's how
the trash chain's awards work right
that's never like that i've been
liberated i i've been exonerated
it wasn't a hot take it was a good day
how do you how do you feel about that
guy
um i mean i wanted another one to win
yeah that's probably one of my worst
takes i've ever said on classes it is
literally the take that always gets
quoted yeah if you want to discredit god
i'd be like god said this anime is bad
yeah but he shouldn't like like
like i'll be like i'll defend [ __ ]
pizza crust or like not eating pizza
crust until the day i die i'm proud of
that [ __ ] i'm just like okay that's
that's that's not my best moment you
know yeah
that's like my dark that's like my dark
past i like trying to get rid of man
oh my goodness
all right the next category next
category is the best out of context clip
i swear to god there's nobody last year
was it bang bang bang one no oh yeah it
was better
yeah
so it's gonna be hard to see what can
top this yeah like what could top it
what could top this what are the
nominees that is sad this is a good one
you go through about 20 emotions in five
seconds like what was going through
i listen back to the conversation that
uh that this happened in i'm like
i don't know it wasn't even a sad it
wasn't even a sorry moment
it was just like it was it's like the
instant sad face for like just a second
and then like snap it was like a snap
back to reality moment right
i still want to know what was going
through your head i don't want to know i
would pay so much money to figure out
what was happening
so much money all right and then title
for the boys and then before you know it
it's like there's like 15 kayaks like 30
boys in this bank just go going kids out
for the boys to sell for the boys
joey being misogynistic
i'm so happy this became a thing
yeah we definitely made anything after
the trash taste uh charities charity
stream yeah it did it did some good
because we've got yeah wallets out of
the boys we made it wholesome guys yeah
we made it wholesome somehow and then of
course it's the this is from the stream
yeah yeah yeah put a v2 clip yeah
the most one funny
clip yeah play it all reacted
accordingly
[Music]
we were supposed to not laugh but
apparently uh it wasn't hard
like i almost laughed looking at us
reacting to it right because
like i wasn't laughing at the clip i was
just like i i was like dead like dead
face and i saw us just like i saw this
out of context clip live and i'm just
like yo it's [ __ ] hilarious man it's
[ __ ] hilarious dog i'd like to think
that this person submitted it like as a
joke but i don't think they did yeah
yeah i think that was serious
unfortunately i just like this is the
such like the best like you got the
whole squad laughing like clip i've ever
seen in my life right
and then next touching anime figures
blindfolded yep what the [ __ ] yeah it's
huge there's there's a lot of bits and
bobs hanging off it
[Music]
oh my god oh my god it just keeps going
i know right [ __ ] i know exactly what
you're talking holy i can't see but i
know exactly where you're talking holy
[ __ ] this just keeps going
[Music]
i guess we're describing very sexual
activities yeah
i know exactly where you know exactly
what you're feeling
it's the ferocity
i don't know what this is yeah i don't
know this one either so i guess
let's have a look yeah i would be i
would gladly be racist
[Music]
all right well there we go what was the
context why did you say that i guess
that's a good out-of-context clip
that's that's so good out of context
because i don't know the context when
would i say that why would i say that
was it like towards kids
no i don't know what it was but like
just the poise you said it in is like i
would gladly be racist like you're like
standing up for something you're really
believing
do you have like a split personality and
like the like the second gun is just
like really racist or something
i think i think you were saying you
would gladly be racist towards wasps oh
that was it wasps yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right well who the winner is
yeah i want to know i have no idea with
this one i really want the sakura mikko
to win yeah i want the soccer yeah i
feel like i know which one's going to
win yeah all right
if i was a betting man god is sad really
right yeah yeah that's a really good one
as well the winner is
drumroll please
god would gladly be racist what
i mean to be fair it is amazing out of
course
that ain't my man
that me that ain't my hands miss you
would indeed gladly be racist what was
the percentage that it won by this was
really close oh yeah
uh god would gladly be racist one with
31.9 percent of the vote okay
second place is god is sad
thirty one point one percent oh one
percent difference
kant is just the best out of context the
only one that can beat me is me he's an
out-of-context machine right here yeah
he's a two-time winner
you try and baby
all the other ones
uh tits out for the boys came in third
with nineteen point eight percent i'll
tell you that
yeah touching anime figures blindfolded
came in fourth with eleven point five so
sad sacramento came last yeah right
sacramento came in fifth with four point
three percent of the vote so sad yeah so
that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
the
thing
come on
yeah no yeah sacramento came in last i
don't know why there's two that was
still holds the title the two-time
champion
someone please take it from me i don't
want this anymore i don't want this
anymore what is the next stop what is
the next category jerry you have the
card as well yes the next category is uh
screen grab of the year oh
so i think we got a little bit of
crossover with this one
uh because i saw some of the nominations
but uh there are a lot of i guess this
is like out of context but just still
images yeah you know
it's kind of like the same energy uh but
you have even less context because
there's no clip to go along with yeah
sure all right let's see what the
nominations are oh sad gone again
wide-eyed gun angry aki
i love this one i love this one you need
to see the full picture for you yeah
yeah yeah yeah
me in a banana clown
i don't really want to do that connor
takes his pants off that's that was
using a lot of me yeah yeah yeah and
then uh oh and i guess it's the sakura
miko us not like no it's it's it's not
sakura it's just like it's just like
okay so this is actually really [ __ ]
hard because i don't know what my
favorite is i think my favorite maybe is
just trash taste in a nutshell yeah uh
just because like you like you might
like
imagine it okay you're a few episodes
behind on trash taste you know you don't
know you'd forget that you were doing
like a 24-hour livestream you see that
on your timeline and you're like what
the [ __ ] is going on with trash taste
was actually a moment of like oh man i
haven't listened to the trash in so long
i wonder what they're doing here
you've missed one episode of trash taste
oh my god wide-eyed god i don't know how
your eyes did i love what i got i don't
even remember like what what did you
what was said that made you react like i
don't even remember like you're talking
about people like you're drinking
budweiser
you're talking about like out of context
going here man i don't [ __ ] you though
if i remember correctly someone said
something that you were like oh yeah i
assume someone said that's what makes
you get
why am i taking off my pants i don't
remember why i did that i don't know
either like your hand is like on the
belt yeah i already got it off i also
just love how an image from like five
years ago from a member that's not even
here it's like nominated like why is
that it is a great image though yeah
yeah no trash taste but yeah i mean it's
still it's still on the meme verse i
guess yeah yeah what what would you say
is your favorite trash stations in a
nutshell uh it's either that or angry
aki as well which is just uh what was
what was that photo was the context was
the context of that the context was so
like the full image is on the screen
right now but it's it's aki looking
pissed off because she was uh like
like sick like classic right from where
we went on a bus tour yeah yeah and i'm
talking to my friend's girlfriend at the
time we're just having a conversation
and takis is looking really pissed off
looking at me because she was really
sick
but out of context it just looks like
she's pissed off me talking to another
yeah yeah it's amazing it's literally
like that meme image of just like the
girl looking pissed and like the guy
looking
back yeah yeah yeah honestly yeah but
yeah i i really love that image overall
and uh but i gotta say trash taste in a
nutshell
like you could there's so much in this
detail there's so much detail in this
image if you just look at it that you
just like discover something new it's
like a piece of art the longer you look
at it the more impressive yeah because
like you look at it you're like why why
is god in a clown costume why is joey in
a banana suit why is connor playing a
monkey i didn't come donation
and then it's just like what what
current sigma comes what what is going
on that's so
i love how like there's just so much
[ __ ] on the table
this is the [ __ ] the most disgusting
table like it's so it's such a chaotic
image that i just i that's my favorite
out of context all right would you like
to know who was the winner yes yes yes
sir the winner of screen grab of the
year goes to
connor takes off his pass
too fair i think that one's used a lot
yeah yeah yeah yeah that is useful
in a row it's me wearing the same
[ __ ] shirt and screen grab of the
year i'm wearing so so i'm like out of
context clifford yeah then connor comes
along with like best screening grab of
the year twice in a row twice in a row
twice oh my gosh i do like this one i
can't remember why though i just thought
it was quite funny when people people
always reply to it with every tweet i do
they always reply with this
every single because because you could
fit it with so many different yeah yeah
yeah it's like excitement but it's also
like horniness yeah it's like it's just
like the my body is ready
thank you thank you viewers yes
so what was the breakdown uh connor
takes off his pants one with thirty two
point four percent that was quite fun
yeah trash taste in a nutshell came in
second with 20.4
third with 19.3 of course of course and
then angry aki came in fourth with 12.8
percent of the vote nice nice and fifth
was banana clown joey
i mean that was just terrifying i i
don't blame you
yeah i thought i got i thought banana
joey would be the uh
banana clown joey would be the worst oh
sorry i'm reading it wrong why did i
gone did indeed come
you came in last with like 7.2 percent
of that yeah
[Music]
what's the next offer oh foxy
we got the most degenerative moment well
i think it's going to be one of you
right because i'm very wholesome i don't
know man you had some degenerate moments
yeah everyone has some degenerate
moments but uh let me just check that i
have yeah it's nice what are the
nominees what are the nominees
okay okay we've got mainly talks about
sweat and spit this is from our cooking
special yeah play the clip have you ever
licked sweat
i mean not on purpose
okay and how did it taste i know what
sweat is mainly i know but like i know
it's salty please don't tell me you
butchered your husband
not on purpose
a true mailing moment this is this is
like a normal moment if you hang out
with maelyn enough she'll just say some
things and like i'm glad that at least
one of the moments has finally been
caught on camera so it's moments like
this where i'm like i'm so glad i'm on
meleen's good side yeah i don't want to
be like i don't know what the [ __ ] she's
gonna do like you can you can literally
see me processing like where do i even
start with this you know you know when a
friend says something and you're like
yeah what
uh
how like
i love
and like the thing is right actually um
a bit of the the full conversation had
to be cut down yes right now for like 40
minutes yeah yeah yeah yeah so what you
see what you saw in the trash taste uh
what in the trash day special was a cut
down version
of uh of the full conversation because
she was saying right this was cut out
she was saying that uh the the sweat of
the chef has like a slight like effect
on the taste of whatever we're cooking
right and uh and that's why that's why
we were talking about sweat being a
seasoning yeah because i got cuts out so
i mean out of context i'm just like i
just i just go to mainland it's like oh
so you want to see one has to go like
like that yeah yeah just like just wipe
out forehead
yeah so the context behind that was
mainly was talking about how swell was
like a seasoning that like changed the
flavor of the food she's so gross you
didn't need to see that part of the
conversation obviously like it was cut
out for a reason god bought an ass
holder for his phone oh yeah oh yeah
yeah which is used over there actually
yeah yeah i mean we're still using it
right now
it's just an ass
i'm gonna have to blow that
it's literally just an oh this is like
the this is like the way they get sucked
into a wall right now stuck in the wall
you only get half the figure so it's
just the ass
i feel this is like a one more combo for
me
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think two of these
are wombo combo just me and joey just
being absolute degenerate i just love
how you described it you're like it's
just an ass
ass to ass
baby
and then next up we have groping
bumblebee oh my god oh my god oh whoa
what the hell oh my god i thought we
were still showing the [ __ ] don't
worry there's plenty to spare what stuff
oh my god oh that's my hand
oh what's this oh that's my hand oh poor
bumblebee like full-on grabs the croc at
one point
yeah i think i think he's caught off in
this clip but i remember i remember like
cupping it i was just like i remember
feeling like oh what's that so smooth
what were you trying to get like a
massive [ __ ] it was like female 1
i don't know i just i just wanted to
feel the entire thing just so i could be
100 sure that's it that's it that's the
only reason and then finally we have uh
gant and connor reveal their lewd anime
figures play the club this is from one
of my favorite artists yom all right
okay i'll give it to you that's pretty
[ __ ] hot
[Laughter]
let's go
vigorous energy i made a massive mistake
like giving it to us yeah because i
remember you just inspect like i just
had to like appreciate the detail yeah
like on unlike the cooch like i'm just
like god damn is that i was like is that
what that looked like
it was awesome i loved it i mean i guess
as much as degenerate as that was it's
got to be painted it's got to be the one
right i'll be shocked i'll be shocked
yeah i'll be disappointed if it's not
the main all right let's find out i hope
so so i can give a [ __ ]
how does it feel to be like the most
degenerate person in trash taste melon
let's see who won yeah that's you oh
it's me oh i'm sorry i'm sorry he's like
yeah
guys guys guys anyone all right let's
find out and the winner of the most
degenerate moment is
melin talks about sweet spit and sweats
well deserved well done melin you have
somehow in like even though you're on
camera for like a tenth of the time it's
like not even a tenth like a hundredth
of the time she's been on three videos
yeah you have somehow won the most
degenerate moment
in trash it wasn't even a competition he
wasn't even
what was it close actually was it close
no it wasn't
that's all we need to know that's all we
need to know can i just know the
percentage
what do you think it was 70. 72.1 oh my
god
i knew it i know
i didn't even need to know the rest
that's that's
melon
won her first trash chase award she's
gonna come to the office later today and
we're gonna tell her that yeah yeah yeah
this episode is sponsored by expressvpn
did you know huge tech companies in
america pay next to nothing in taxes
meaning they barely give anything back
to society that made them rich
they may not do a lot of giving but they
sure do a lot of taking the audacity
ladies and gentlemen i'm talking about
how these tech companies enrich
themselves by taking your personal data
they grab your web history email
metadata and video searches to create a
detailed profile on you and then sell
that off to the highest bidder companies
aren't just selling products anymore
they're selling you to protect your
identity and data from these tech giants
i recommend using expressvpn every time
you go online expressvpn makes you
anonymous online by camouflaging your ip
address and replacing it with a
different secure ip of your choice
expressvpn also encrypts all your data
so that it's protected from hackers and
anyone else who tries to spy on you and
what i like the most about expressvpn is
how easy it is to use just download the
app on your phone or computer tap one
button and you're protected this is
expressvpn.com
trash taste and get three months free on
a one year package that's expressvpn.com
to learn more back to the episode all
right let's go on to the next category
then well this is quite fitting uh
because it's one that is close to my
heart yeah that's the saltiest moment
yes
i had to take the jacket off for this
one yeah because it's gonna get hot
yeah so let's see what the nominations
are yeah yeah all right we have connor
not winning the cooking special
this is definitely sold this is a salty
moment that has persisted to this day
yeah connor to this day has not let
maelyn go from true
learns that the dead sea is a lake
i'm pretty salty about that
i think we're all serious
i didn't vote for that i i i didn't care
uh conor not getting points because of
his own rules oh this is the feel good
ink one right oh this was the feel good
very very you were very it was it was
like that was one of the red songs when
it was just like i could it was like
real real i was shocked i don't know why
i was so salty for that part like
normally i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
i think it's because you you realized
you [ __ ] yourself over normally i
wouldn't care yeah this time for some
reason i cared so much about it
because like because like this this
exact moment was like energy of just
like little brother is just like [ __ ]
like like it was like i told you to get
off the xbox you're just like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right fine
uh the boys finding out they gave
budweiser
that's just like
shameful that was a shameful moment we
were very salty about it we were salty
about i love how none of these uh are
from normal episodes
oh yeah cause we're not salty now one
from a special and the other yeah yeah
we're way salty on after dark
i feel like the amount of times we argue
about answers in half the dark i feel
like you can i feel like four or four
categories just isn't enough sometimes
you know i'm shocked that some of the
figure special stuff wasn't in here that
was a very salty special oh sure yeah
yeah yeah well like trying to decide
like delegate like points
i believe that was like more
i i think we're going to see it again on
like the best arguments oh because like
because i think like how do you
distinguish between salty and arguments
right
the level of anger with an argument yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i believe these
for saltiest moments i believe if
they're because none of these arguments
right yeah so i think it's like they're
just temper tantrums yeah they're just
these are just tantrums okay meline's
scoring of mine and dance was actually
utter [ __ ]
i loved it i love my face
so i can't remember what she said but
she did come on to defend herself on
trash days after dark i don't remember
what episode that was which one do you
think is going to win this is hard holy
[ __ ] i really don't know like this is
one of the hardest ones right because
they are all
really really salty moments
like my god i'm probably going to say
just purely from the fact that it was
like the most infamous moment in trash
taste i would say the budweiser one
could be could because that one got mean
to [ __ ] yeah i think it's gonna be
either that one or the cooking special
maybe i don't know i don't know
i don't think it's gonna be the dead so
do we have do we have clips to play with
this yeah okay so shall we see how salty
we look in the clips yeah
yeah that means i won
let's go
it's all right gone you you tied with
connor yeah absolute joke come here come
here connor come on now i don't want to
see you my fellow man how much you pay
me lean huh how much you pay me lead huh
[ __ ] up
like like like like uh physically no on
camera it doesn't look like corn is that
salty but connor was very connor was
actually salty on camera like off camera
he just he just like that's like he got
saltier as like the time went on like
it was like fine wine but just like with
salt you know just aged more as time
went on
all right so we played the gun loans
about the dead sea he's not a lake it's
a salt lake
[ __ ]
wait so what
what
sorry sorry let me just i am losing
brain cells
right now
where you would call
a landlocked lake
the dead sea
i think that's the only time in trash
takes history where god has clipped the
audio
like that what was like a cl i was like
oh my god people listening on headphones
i think i was just so disgusted i was
just like right like you know when you
just realize like like something has
very gone wrong something has gone wrong
with the system you literally threw down
the white ball like what the i'm like
the world is broken like what is the
point anymore you know people often lie
i've i discovered that today all right
let's play uh conor not getting points
because of his own rules i don't want
the point i just don't want god to get
the people great agreement we both get
the point and job gets nothing let's
feel good inc i got girls feel good what
was that that you said to me literally
like two three questions ago
i'll give you a point for gorillas you
said that you need to just get the song
exactly right what the [ __ ] you want the
one you look at this corner you are
literally the one who you are
this is like karma compilation oh
oh this feels so good
i think that wasn't like so much a salty
moment as much as it like persisted for
like a few rounds after that yeah if we
had an instant karma uh award yeah
definitely if we didn't that would
absolutely win yeah all right and then
uh the boys find out they gave budweiser
a 7.5 we want to forget about this
czech one okay i said it's the check one
as well i don't know the german beers so
i'm just 50 50. it tastes german all
right ready okay three two one
no
no
no
how does this taste good
that like i like like i
i remember like i don't know if that's
salty because you can you can really
feel the despair in the third no that i
shouted that that was like an oscar
award worthy like no
i was like that's some real [ __ ] right
there you know how they say like no is
like unrealistic dialogue you know you
shouldn't include in your script that's
obviously not true that's some real [ __ ]
right there's true despair right there
if you're feeling true dismay yes you do
shout out no
oh my god yeah now that i think about it
it's probably it might have a chance of
winning but like that was not so much
salty as that was just like shame that
was shame and despair all right let's
find out then i guess yeah jacket is off
for this one the winner is
connor not getting the point
you know what that's worthy that's
pretty worth it that is
is worthy god damn it what were the
percentages for that this was really
close oh i'm not surprised this was one
of this is probably the hardest category
this is the hardest one yeah uh connor
you won with
31.6 of the vote okay
and you came in second as well
with thirty one point one percent of the
vote or five point four not winning the
cooking special i'll take that i'll tell
you that
[Laughter]
anyone who can be saltier than me
and then which one was better budweiser
or older uh budweiser was third with
thirty point nine percent of the vote oh
wow wait what did see one get there dead
c came in with six point four percent of
the vote wow damn that was like a three
like a three horse race then i mean
that's like i i thought the dead sea one
would get a little bit more cause like
that's a rare sight where ghant is salty
yeah like you don't often see that
all right wow that was very close all
right next up next one is the most
monkey award
well uh we're probably gonna expect uh
like about six nominations from i've
completely forgotten the nominations of
this okay first one is oh it's one of
two okay there's quite a few yeah all
right the first one is the boys not
running away from a gas canister in the
campfire
that was the rare moment where connor
was not the monkey yeah that's when
we're going like conor was like the
neanderthal to us like us monkeys at
that point you know like he he was like
more involved than us
higher than you
just watching this guy holding this gas
canister on fire i mean yeah it was
pretty it was pretty scary and i think a
lot of people like this because this is
like one of the most viewed like tick
tocks right i think so yeah well like it
it initially was one of our most
beautiful tick tocks by the way follow
us on tick tock and youtube shorts as
well youtube shorts
connor bought four tio figures
yeah that was pretty monkey yeah i did
forget about that rule
yeah yeah dude connor's four deal
figures count as only one duplicate um
so
basically yeah uh you know how
haha
you know how we nervous
i've never had a moment where i'm just
like i'm not that i'm about to hear
[ __ ] right now you know an argument
is going to be strong when it starts
with um
so basically yeah
i was trying to there was some decent
excuse but there was none i just
completely forgot about that rule yeah
yeah yeah until
you know until after it was over because
what makes it even more monkey is that
you would have clearly been like ahead
in the race because you were like
clearly ahead in points and then you
just kept like deducting points from
yourself like because of you because you
bought so many d.o figures
so funny all right next one is god
forgets how to do long division play the
clip calculate 111
111 divided by 11. [ __ ]
i'm hoping god will get this one because
i didn't oh
apparently after that stream finished i
was like watching back on the episode
apparently i just did it completely
wrong
but i still somehow got the correct
answer so i mean i mean i don't know why
i don't know i mean i don't know why
it's god forgets how to do long division
because me and connor
me and connor are in the same boat here
well technically i forgot as well
because i didn't even do it right
because like we like at least you like
had like a decent attempt yeah i believe
like me and connor just like gave up
even
like the two engineers here like we just
couldn't figure it out
there's a calculator in it yeah
the boys get confused by the richter
scale oh yeah this is very recent one
there's a reason why
whoever designed the richter scale
really [ __ ] up it's not uh linear do
you mean exponential expert i think
that's what i think logarithmic is
logarithmic thank you okay but you were
trying to explain the exponential
you said the right word but you were
saying the wrong thing the original
point i was trying to make was that they
you they put it in a scale that is not
comprehensible by the normal human
person which we are which we are
literally proving
right now
i mean like compared to the others i
would say this is on like the lower end
right yeah because okay we were arguing
like actually both me and connor were
both right and we were both wrong yeah
yeah in in a sense here we because i was
like oh i said the richter scale was a
logarithmic scale which it is i didn't
realize that logarithms are the opposite
of exponentials which they are so those
are like
those are two different things i
remember i read up on it after the
episode yeah i still didn't get it the
fact that we needed actual like
mathematicians to do like a [ __ ]
three paragraph long explanation of it
just proves that you know it's it might
not be the most monkey moments maybe
because we are engineers they would
expect higher you know it's not
recommendable
when you when you've got an engineering
degree but you don't use it for like six
years you're kind of
kind of yeah
look man i can't do log i can't do
[ __ ] long divisions what makes you
think i know what a [ __ ] logarithmic
scale is you know
we've got a couple of other nominees a
couple of nominees oh do we really yeah
that was one of two oh wow okay so this
one is the boy scream jojo drink counter
i love this clip i stand
that's good let's get clear i like that
one that was like that we didn't plan
that
everyone knows about scripting that was
like the rare moment where we all shared
the same brainstorm not just like me and
joey that was like yeah that was like we
literally de-evolved into monkeys i i
think that's like the most probably the
most monkey right there honestly just
jojo fans in a nutshell am i right god
and joey share the same brain cells we
only have one clip of this yeah we got
like some of the biggest bangers have
had the girlfriend in the title we've
got a domestic girlfriend we've got
rent-a-girlfriend girlfriend girlfriend
there's so many other moments
this is the feeling i i feel like
there's no one moment it's just like
just every moment where we like that was
one like it was a subtle moment where i
said the same thing i have to ask that
why does god get scared by his own piss
stream why is that
oh i think that's from the camping story
right oh oh
yeah play the clip though one of you
guys say something funny you start
laughing i look over and i'm just like
huh you know the boys are just being
boys i look back over and i see
something someone's breath just like
just like going towards like a white
cloud yeah like a white cloud i'm like
[ __ ] there's there's a monster hiding in
that bush and then i soon realized
literally half a second in that it's
just my piss steaming
[Music]
that's that has to be top three right i
mean that has to be told no that was
like very monkey that was neanderthal
being scared of like wild animals you
know i was like i was like
my favorite story is just like imagining
it like in context right you just turn
around
oh it's just my pee
because i was slightly intoxicated at
that point and i was just yeah yeah
what else does that say i mean like i i
do still feel
the jojo moment is the most i wouldn't
be disappointed if it wasn't the georgia
one i don't think it will be you don't
think so what do you think so what do
you think
i don't know actually there's a lot yeah
there's there's a lot of good stuff here
all right well let's find out there all
right right here so the winner for the
most monkey moment goes to
god gets scared by his own peers
that is the most that's pretty [ __ ]
monkey to be fair all right all right i
didn't say it was interesting that's not
the monkey award for this year you got
the monkey award give me give me that
give me that
i'll take you i'll tell you
i'll take it home
what the percentages are
uh got won that one with
uh hold on
twenty seven point two percent of the
vote
okay yeah yeah okay there was more
nominations here yeah
top four top four uh obviously was the
first second was the boys not running
away from a gas canister with twenty one
point six percent
third was gone and joey sharing one
brain cell with nineteen point six
percent of the vote
and in fourth place connor
behavior that's just culture
all right what's the next category then
best story oh oh
okay okay i mean we had a lot of great
stories
what were the nominations for this one
find out uh god was in a band
yeah that is a great story play the clue
i was actually in a band myself i don't
i don't know if i were you yeah i don't
know if i've ever talked about this no
you've never tried we've never talked
about have i ever never mentioned never
mentioned it where would you even play
yeah what did you play i play guitar
what seriously i'm
no i was offended because i was like why
did you not tell me yeah we could have
started you're like years ago you're
like you are yeah how dare you not tell
me we could have brought back nine and a
half pounds years ago dude i know what
the hell yeah i mean like that was yeah
that was a fun story to tell just
because i completely forgot that i
hadn't told it before uh because i think
i did tell it on like a previous part or
i mentioned it
uh so i think i just assumed i had
already mentioned it before right right
um i was offended yeah
there's the boys went camping posted a
couple of photos of us going camping and
uh so many people thought they were like
yeah
sometimes we just hang out with our
cameras
it's definitely like a full episode yeah
yeah but i mean we had so many good
stories from that cam trip though yeah
there wasn't like one story there's just
just like that that camp trip at least
it was just like a gold mine of stories
yeah and then there's qantas quarantine
hotels had armed guards wow this is what
made it they took us all the way from
canada airport which is like very south
of tokyo yeah to ryogoku i can get to
this hotel and i [ __ ] you not there is
like 40 armed guards at this hotel for
like 20 of us it was ridiculous
i think one of my favorite things about
this story isn't like it's the dichotomy
between like our two experiences i think
that what made the moment and the story
was just like the absolutely
yeah yeah
honestly like a prison
and then oh this one oh this one
and then i look over and in the corner
of my eye i see a fat [ __ ] cockroach
i just ran in my room just like grabs
grab this mouse pad that was the closest
thing and just ran back out
i grabbed the tit side of things right
whammy ones didn't work whammer twice
didn't work so i'm just like [ __ ]
like
truly degenerate moment god i love how
you had to mention that you were
grabbing the tits like i just i did you
know when you just
remember like the most vivid details you
know you know
i remember that feeling in my hand it
felt great baby eye cup in my hand
and then we thought i managed to try to
scam us we couldn't find a clip for this
but like i remember the story where i
believe joey told
the story
yeah melin first emailed us and i
thought it was a scammy you thought it
was a scam because uh we didn't know
that book walker slash cater coward
tried to contact us yeah they were like
big company trying to contact small and
cheaper no like yeah yeah where's the
nigerian prince just just tell me where
the nigerian prince is okay right oh we
have a clip oh we do have a clip
remember the first time that maylene
messaged me like to work with bulk
walker yeah i thought it was a scare
honestly honestly i thought the same
thing as well
first one i [ __ ] deleted it
immediately i was like nah that's a scam
get out of that and then meleen misses
me like emailed me again after a week
and she's like i don't know if you read
my last email but uh we're interested in
working with you and i'm like
oh this [ __ ] don't delete that again
i [ __ ] deleted that [ __ ]
and the final number and the final yeah
melin tried luring her cat with yogurts
oh this edit is amazing the moment you
open the yogurt cap he knows it's like
and then he's like
so i opened the yogurt and started
swishing around
and he finally came out
that's such a chaotic clip
that would be a good like out of context
yeah that would be a great out of
context but just like joey just like
meowing in the background and mainly
just like so i tried to get i tried to
lure my cat out with yogurt
i tapped the thing and then the story
comes so meline had an app that was
apparently they would translate what
your cat is saying and me and joe are
like [ __ ] so we tried to
meow into it to see what it would be i
made it once yeah yeah that was half of
the clip the second half of the clip was
just melin literally trying to draw her
with your cool who was stuck in a wall
mind you
so bizarre like a joker it doesn't make
sense like you know when like you do
something in the dream and it makes
sense in the dream and then you wake up
you're like what the what kind of logic
was that that is literally that story
that is a dream yeah that's a fever
dream right oh man any of these could
win honestly i would say
i i hope it's the main lean one
just i i generally don't know maybe gone
in the band yeah john the band yeah
cause that was such a big deal yeah
that caused the stir yeah i think that
story dropped yeah i think that's like
that one was probably like most like
character development i guess this is
how you would call it character yeah
yeah
yeah yeah in terms of like funniest i'm
just like mailing with a cat cause that
was the second time i'd heard it yeah
she told me that and i was like pissing
myself the first time she told me and i
was like maybe you gotta tell this on
stream it's like the best story ever all
right let's find out though all right i
can't tell us who won and the best story
goes to
god was in a bag
of course yeah
uh i was in the band maybe i'll pick up
the guitar once again we're going to
start a band man
we're going to start off
what do you want what are you going to
do triangle
guitar me on vocals conor and triangle
10 and a half pounds let's do it yeah
yeah i'm glad my band story uh i'm glad
my experience as a band uh was good for
something
what were the percentages
god won that one with forty two point
four percent oh okay that's good
his epic battle with the cockroach also
came in second with 31
stories man
that's third place what's third place
third place was you guys going camping
with nine point eight percent okay okay
okay okay i mean that was just a story
gold mine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right well i guess uh what's the next
category oh i think i have it yeah yeah
what is it
biggest clown it's like looking good
that i'm doing this one so yeah so
there's a lot of clownery and trash
taste as you know
it's most of trash clown taste i mean a
lot sometimes it is just clown taste
sometimes this is the circus yes uh like
most times actually sometimes sometimes
it's like when aren't we the circus so
obviously there is going to be our
biggest clown out of all of us all right
let's check out the nominations check
out the nominations
all right so that's oh my god these
pictures
so i guess me gone joey chris melina
iron mouse i guess
why is chris nominated twice guys
what is that picture of you connor
[ __ ] hell oh my live stream like it's
like mid-exorcism
i love the shot of you joe from like the
spicy ramen challenge going insane yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah luke did such a good
job at that dude that was literally like
like a perfect shot for like the go the
anime character going insane man
honestly if we could all get these uh so
i have one i want chris to win again i
want crystal you won last time oh [ __ ]
did you win
the other thing
that's just like selective memories like
chris won last time it's definitely
lovely christmas i definitely didn't win
let's see if you get two years in a row
then all right
i mean there's not much to say about
this you know we're clowns you know
we're all clowns
do you guys think it's like between me
and someone is there it has to be chris
i i i think i have a good chance of
winning this yeah
sure like your class i i think i was
respectable like like not like not
respectful but like on equal terms you
know you know i said pizza crust and all
that but even that didn't bring me to
the clown category i just think like the
bread the bread the breadstick was like
so strong that that was like the solo
carry you know well let me have a peep
first and i'll announce it all right why
are you peeping first right i tried a
little peep so i can do a dramatic
reveal all right [ __ ] it was me
what was it you again
[Applause]
two years baby two minutes two years
why are you voting for me i'm not the
clown well you know well what are the
percentages let's find out what are the
percentages uh connor was the biggest
clown with 42.1 percent for the vote who
came second uh god was the second
biggest clown with thirty three point
one percent
she's like majority is like yusuf
[ __ ] hell who was third people didn't
slam it twice that was chris third was
chris all right
oh i'll take being suck you know what i
said the bread take i was literally
wearing a clown costume in the 24 hour
live stream and i still didn't win next
next 24 hour live stream i feel like
they're doing it just despite me
[Laughter]
how dare you like every like a
nomination like for the saltiest moment
every year should be conor winning the
biggest clown because he was very salty
last year so salty in fact that he's
forgotten about it he's just wiped it
from his memory now i thought chris was
chris this one repressed this again this
is going in the repression memory bank
all right the next one though is the
opposite it's the biggest chart it's the
biggest charge is that the opposite this
is the opposite of two personalities
there was no in between all right what
are the nominees
oh you got some nice photos oh you got
some nice photos okay but we also got
demonday's karen yeah actually now i
can't come yeah um i mean i've i put my
vote in for come i put my phone in for
comments
oh we have more as well yeah we have oh
some more
all right we got jan caisson
you know that thing that doesn't exist
anymore i mean if we're speaking on like
literal terms there's probably like a
clear winner here right obviously
literally
literally the biggest
um but yeah i mean like i i gotta put in
my vote in for come i mean i'm pointing
my vote he
by himself i think we figured out he
donated like over there over ten
thousand dollars i think it was i think
it's over fifteen thousand over fifteen
thousand so without loss without him we
would have don't like raised i think
like a hundred and eighty thousand it
was total 180 000 total so like he was
15 000 of that which was like [ __ ]
one man put in the world yeah
[Music]
the biggest chad is of this year
the biggest chad of trash taste 2022 is
calm
well deserved only on trash taste will
you ever see a [ __ ] card that just
looks like this come lower case as well
lowercase calm
thank you come thank you everyone give
their thanks to come we don't know who
you are but you are indeed the biggest
you are indeed the biggest well-deserved
well-deserved what was the percentage of
come vote
i think everyone can agree that [ __ ] was
the biggest challenge yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i feel like i feel like if you didn't
vote for come you probably didn't know
the context of why [ __ ] was there yeah
you missed out on the charity stream no
one knows what cam is yeah but we're
know that we have it no one knows who
comes no one knows who it is what it is
yes
but he definitely is not only the
current sigma but uh the the forever
signature
all right what's the foreign one
john
um so the next category who's who is who
was like what was like the other
it's it's irrelevant it's okay okay
it's a relationship
is the biggest chat that's all you need
to know
it's your boy josh the mangalad here to
let you know that this episode is
sponsored by honey the easy way to shop
online with your iphone or computer as a
certified zoomer you know that all the
shopping i do is online but sometimes i
want to save that money i want to get
those promo codes but they don't come as
easily as i thought so what do you do
you use honey instead because thanks to
honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey's the
free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best ones it finds to your card look i'm
gonna break it down how it works okay
just just listen to this imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite sites
when you check out the honey button
appears and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds there's
honey searches for coupons you can find
it for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch those prices
drop i love shopping for a lot of vinyls
and records for my record player and i
actually saved around twenty dollars on
an album i really really wanted that is
an absolute steal thanks to honey i'd
never recommend something i don't use so
get honey by going to joinhoney.com
trash taste that's joinhoney.com
trash taste links in the description
back to the episode best nickname so
like
we're not wait are we pulling nicknames
though from last year no we're not there
these are the ones that were made
last year i oh i mean gone or me naming
gone steve
i thought it was karen yeah no no no
steve jobs i won last year
i think we've realized who connor's
voted for by his selective memory i
didn't remember if that was a nominee or
not it was a nominee was it yeah i voted
you sure i i didn't vote i put 20 votes
in i i thought it would be insider
trading so i didn't vote yeah yeah so i
mean jobs won last year i mean so we get
a lot of memes and a lot of nicknames
that come out of our trash chase
recordings
i i thought i actually thought this year
that we didn't have any nicknames i was
like can we do we have enough
to get like nominations and then i saw
the nominations i'm like oh there's even
more than last year
oh yeah we we had a lot okay let's let's
let's see them then that's one of the
nominations yeah
doctor
okay we had doctor ligma what a great
legendary doctor legendary little baby
man
i mean i think that's supposed to be
gone but you know yeah yeah josh the
monk
what where did that come from
oh but for one i don't watch anime
anymore yeah two one guy at a convention
called me josh on ironically yeah
so it was it was josh the manga
i mean that's not a nickname she is our
mother all right and then god god oh
that's your yeah
that was someone mishearing my nickname
and then uh and then dc news easy news
from the trpg stream yes wow solid names
i don't know who's gonna win that's all
what was the first one again go back to
the first page
dr ligma dr ligma oh man i love dr i
really hope little baby man doesn't win
i think if i was a betting man i'd
probably be at mister i would say mr
apple oh that one got a lot of mileage
yeah that was that was like like when
when chris came on and he just said
affable now he's just known as like the
affable guy that was the that was the
episode where everyone in the world
learned the word apple yeah before that
and then like now i can't stop using it
yeah
[Music]
yeah all right let's find out let's find
out who won man and the best nickname of
2022
is
mr raphael
hey
good on you chris
you are mr affable you know the downside
of this it means that chris has a chance
to win more than one award
you only won one last year yeah sure
sure he's gonna be so made out [ __ ]
all right what were the percentages
there well top three just named top
three
top three top was mr affable with 32.7
percent of the vote second was little
baby man with 20.9 percent of them no
actually i'd say that thank you chris
thank you thank you thank you for thanks
for watching yeah
and josh the manga lab came in third
16.3 yeah
goddammit that's all i wanted to hear
god damn it all right fine
all right what's the next one connor oh
it's me you're right that's right next
up is oh my favorite best complaining
about america awards oh we have plenty
of these
god knows like how do we know where do
we where do we know how do we begin yeah
uh let's have a look at the nominations
then boys shall we yeah all right so the
first one is explaining why budweiser is
back if there is an instant karma
compilation this would also be on it all
right
the thing is i never tried a budweiser
up until now because all i've heard is
that it tastes like [ __ ]
so that's why i never tried it but now i
kind of like it
sizes in japan versus sizes in the us i
think that's talking about coffee sizes
and food sizes oh yeah i see um i guess
we don't need to watch that clip right
yeah yeah that's fine i mean i i don't
think we need to watch all these clips
because they're going to be very long
clips
there's a lot of so we can explain them
because i remember most of these
uh there's very few things i do remember
on trash days but complaining about
america is definitely one of them
um so yeah explaining why budweiser is
bad um i'm not sure if that was like a
complaining about america moment as much
as it was otherwise it is america yeah
it's amazing it's it's the mountains
as much as you can as much as you're
just complaining about american beer
period yeah yeah and then we uh we
definitely shot ourselves in the foot uh
and then in the in our own faces
afterwards um sizes in japan versus
sizes in the usa coffee and stuff like
that yeah everything yeah everything in
america just being true everything is
just everything is just too big yeah
also yeah america's stupid way of
writing dates okay it is come on you got
it i mean this isn't even a trash taste
com uh complaining yeah it's it's it's
just like this is the wall complaining
yeah yeah and of course the chef chef
mac insults new york on the cooking
special in like record speech i do like
this one i love this one because it was
just such a
unplanned moment yeah where we just had
like we were just trying to be wholesome
you know we're trying to be comforting
we had to like we had a guest on just
hadn't wanted to have a nice
conversation immediately complains about
america like it wasn't even scripted no
no no no
i was just gonna ask like oh so how did
you get your position or what's your
experience and you just like yeah so uh
and then one time we had meline on and
we needed some backup so we asked meleen
what she thinks about us talking [ __ ]
about america yeah which uh was us
complaining about us complaining about
america yeah and then of course we had
the americans that microwaved their
water yeah i will never forgive that
yeah i'll never forgive you that's
unforgivable yeah that is a war crime
that is geneva convention defying right
and it's it's funny because the only one
the one of the biggest ones aside from
this one
one of the biggest ones i've seen
america still defend is the microwave of
their water
how could you defend that this is how
you know that you know that eclipse is
like i will never forgive the japanese
that's like you'll never forgive the
americans
i just don't get it it just doesn't make
sense yeah
um for this one though i do hope the
chef mac one wins just i want the
american microwave on the room either of
those could honestly win but it's it's
between those two just i love the chef
mac one just for how unplanned it was
and just like the like the fast it was
the fastest bonding experience to be
like oh you're one of us okay okay
you'll get a yo you'll fit right in
you'll fit right there definitely all
right yeah well the winner is gentlemen
yes let us know if or not it's
americans microwaving their walls
well
you know what i i i feel like i feel
like the rest of the world united in
yeah in like
voting for that w plus i asked plus i
cared yeah exactly right
what was the percentage that at one
uh that one won with thirty seven point
three percent of the vote oh no
that's pretty big what came second
second was you guys explaining why
budweiser is bad with eighteen point
eight percent of the vote yeah fair fair
and americans writing their dates wrong
came in third with 14.5 percent of the
vote so i think it was just so good at
predicting this yeah i think it's just
like the world uniting about what they
can like it's everything every every
person but americans and like
coming together to be like what do we
actually agree on what's the common
complaint yeah what's the most common
complaint
all right joey what's the next category
the next one oh this one's going to be a
hot contender
best meme
we had a lot of great memes that the
subreddit and the twitter have created
fantastic matches honestly
any of these could win but uh let's see
what the nominations are all right so
for starters we have the dark timeline
yes which i'm a little like behind on
because i think this kind of came onto
the subreddit when i deleted reddit off
my phone yeah this is this has come
pretty recently yeah um and we haven't
talked about it i guess yeah but it's
still pretty timely because it would
have been two weeks i guess since the
dark timeline started um what the [ __ ]
yeah i like
all i know is that it makes fate look
normal yeah yeah i'm kind of waiting for
it to finish yeah let's let's go through
that's all good let's go through all the
categories first before and god said
of course yes of course uh iron master
christmas
and then evil trash
taste so like i think the biggest
difference between
this year's memes and last year's memes
is that
like our reddit has a hive mind of its
own now there are two memes here that we
did not create or we had zero hand
which i which is great it's
there was like such good fan art out of
it and everything like that like the i
think one of my favorites is the one
where like uh iron mouse is piloting a
mech of chris yeah yeah
i think my favorite thing about the iron
mouse is chris meme is that none of us
are in it
like it literally has nothing to do with
trash tastes and yet it's a trash taste
me it just shows that the trash taste
law has gone it has expanded so much
that it's like gone we don't trust
us yeah it doesn't even need us anymore
it was good though because then chris
went on iron mountain's talk show as
well yeah they probably never would have
had no that was like that was like the
full circle and then the timeline which
i believe is still ongoing yeah right to
this day i think i i i would bet my
entire net worth that the timeline is
getting away just because of the recency
of course and the subreddit loves it
they all love it well like it's not just
like the recency because recency bias is
also
like it's it's take like i am
[ __ ]
impressed by the amount of effort that
has gone into this what this is not a
meme anymore this has gone beyond the
meme it's it is
like they're literally pulling they're
literally pulling like a tagashi and
like [ __ ] like graphing everything
out and they're like okay so this
happens while this was happening and
then this happens next yeah it's just
like fake fans and kingdom heart fans
think no one can like defeat them until
like they look like the dark timeline
i'm like okay i bow to my lord like i
looked at like the time and i'm like
[ __ ] you now how would you make sense of
this like there's youtube explainer
videos on the dark timeline are you
serious yeah there's a few oh my god and
like and some of them don't even explain
it very well yeah yeah like i don't
really get it but
yeah and like the thing that blows my
mind the most
is that we have had zero involvement
into it we we did not create it we did
not even say something that like could
like fuel it that fueled it you know
what i mean it it is like our subreddit
completely like just having a maha like
a mind of its own
like it's it's
our subreddit is self-sustaining at this
point honestly these two memes prove it
yeah definitely all right well uh let's
find out then yeah who got the best how
much the dark timeline
yeah let's find out i guess uh so the
winner for the best meme of the year
goes to
the dark timeline yeah not even
not even a surprise congrats sir
congrats congratulations reddit uh your
fan fiction made it
oh my god it's a bad feat
i'm not doing it it's literally a fan
fiction i'm not even joking why are you
going to do them like that joey why are
you going to do like this is so much
more than that jerry it's a cohesive
universe
i didn't sacrifice the past he called
waiting for you to call it a [ __ ] fan
fiction joey i didn't die in an
earthquake me to call it a fanfiction
you don't know what i sacrificed joey it
doesn't even make sense yeah i'm looking
at this and i'm like first of all what
the [ __ ] is that face on the left there
that's from one of my life
i gotta shout out the people who
actually
made this [ __ ] image i know how
difficult and how time consuming it is
to make an image like this
it is this is sponsored by the bbc like
this is the initial timeline
timeline yeah this is like i mean this
is like a really high ether meme you
know this is all yeah yeah this is
extremely high effort
keep it coming
honestly i want to see how it concludes
what percentage did a win by is the real
question
well the dark timeline came in first
with 35.1 percent of that oh wow that's
not as much as i thought it was going to
be yeah
second place is i'm mouse's chris with
of course of course
that have nothing to do with us
timeline is all about but i mean like we
did yeah
yeah we didn't create it
this is like the reddit like giving
themselves the medal i mean like guys we
did a great job
[Music]
um the next category is
uh they actually talked about anime
awards so uh a new one so if you're a
new viewer of trash chase you may not
know this but uh we want we're an anime
podcast no we won't
[Music]
we once said that we were an anime
podcast and i don't know the exact
moment when we were just like no we
started with the intention of being an
anime podcast and then by halfway
we didn't we started with the intention
of
tricking people into thinking we're an
anime podcast
but yeah guys we're definitely an anime
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then uh
definitely it took like way less time
than i thought it would to be like no
we're not an anime product one episode
one episode literally episode two we
don't talk about anime yeah so
we did also talk about anime uh we are a
podcast
yeah yeah i would say i like to think i
like to think every now and then we
spoke about it yeah
we're going to represent our original ip
yeah let's see all right so first of all
connor watch all of mushoku tensei which
i think was a surprise to a lot of
people i'm sorry i'm so proud i'm so
proud i'm still proud
to be fair uh joey thought jesus christ
was okay here we go again here we go
again uh the boys talk about berserk for
30 minutes oh this was when uh mira
sensei passed away this is a shame
because at this point i hadn't read
berserk yeah
and during the manga episode we actually
talked about it it was that also i think
could have been referring to the manga
episode
oh could you i
yeah um
was this the one where we had that
unfortunate timing yeah yeah yeah yeah
so like so like as much as i like
berserk and i'm glad we talked about
berserking for 30 minutes yeah i think
this is actually referring to the manga
episode okay okay yeah yeah okay we
didn't have this point as well yeah yeah
yeah we've talked about we've touched on
bizarre a couple of times yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was amazing okay and then
uh conor and gant try to get joey to
watch arcane arcane's
and then the boys talk about not
watching anime how's that wait hold on
how is that in this award
okay can i can i see this clip yeah yeah
you guys voted for these nominations by
the way it really says a lot about anime
when all it takes is for me to read a
synopsis
and i could probably tell you with 90
accuracy what the first three episodes
of that anime is going to be about in in
a detailed way yeah yeah we were we were
like such an anime podcast that we had
like a [ __ ] 20-minute conversation
about not talking about anime anymore
i remember this conversation i still
stand by at that point yeah definitely
ah well [ __ ] i mean
i purely just from the fact that it was
nominated in the other ones i would
probably have to say
me thinking jesus christ was like i want
that one to win yeah i just wanted to
get something i wanted to get the dobby
i want it so nobody forgets that joey
thinks jiu-jitsu guys is okay i will
keep reminding everyone every day
all right let's find out i guess all
right uh that's not me no it is
absolutely you you picked it up all
right right right
uh and the winner is
john and connor trying to get joey to
watch
oh that's surprising as you should have
watched it yeah yeah i definitely will
watch how many episodes ago was that
like 30.
i think i said episode 77 so that's 30
up like a year ago
it is now zero days uh since arcane was
yeah all right
watch it watch arcane it's amazing when
season two comes out it'll happen all
over again what uh what percentage did
it win by
that one won
with 24.9 percent of the vote oh
in second place with 23.5 percent of the
vote connor watched all of mushook i
would have voted for that one i thought
that would yeah because that was like
surprising i remember because
we talked about anime what what
i call it my recommendation about an isa
guy what
never happens yeah never happens oh wow
all right yeah i like the fact that it's
the they actually talked about anime
awards and uh the arcade
arcade
yeah definitely an anime
everyone everyone's in the wrong
timeline yeah everyone everyone's not
figuring it out the best tangent
so all of trash days essentially the
entirety of this podcast all right
raiding a conversation was an olympic
sport we'd beat the world championship
we'd definitely be the world champions
let's see the nominations what are the
nominations all right i'm gonna do it so
three things you would take to a
deserted island
okay it's not a tangent i get i guess
it's kind of yeah because the question
was suddenly like thrown out of nowhere
right yeah i threw it out there just
randomly okay and then talking about
dreams talking about are we watching the
clips for these you can i i would like
to because i would like to see our
reaction to some of the tangents if they
are real i can't understand yeah play
the first one first can i take a boat
like a really nice yacht
i'll just take my six million dollar
mansion no one said the scale of items i
i can bring why can't i bring a boat
well then i'll bring a jet and get the
[ __ ] out
okay so like
i i think some of these might have like
more like immediate tangents we'll see
we'll see oh because some of these
inspired entire episodes right yeah
you're talking about dreams one i think
it was just one
i don't know led to that oh i think it
was about you talking about sydney
having fever dreams yeah okay then we
went and then the rest of the episode
was just about dreams that that was a
tangent that defined an episode you know
i don't even remember what the [ __ ] we
were talking about that was like
actually one of my favorite episodes to
record because i was just it was just
such a weird conversation that i've
never had before and then conor thinks
dear are the scariest valid valid valid
oh i love this one turkish taxi drivers
are the mafia can you play this clip
actually yeah i want to play this clip
army of taxi drivers ready to beat you
up
like literally my taxi driver bro cause
they're like they're like the mafia of
turkey
dude in turkey they say don't [ __ ] with
bus drivers and taxi drivers [ __ ] with
one of them you you you call up the
entire neighborhood
why do like
that that single handling made me not
want to go to tokyo
[Applause]
yeah and then jan talks about the
touches
i want to watch this one i want to watch
this one because i remember like having
visual shocked this way yeah i think so
basically you know hitachi
sacrificed his whole life being for the
greater good that he believed in
i sure he had to fill in at a age that
you know even he had no understanding or
conscious about okay stop laughing [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i think conor sums it up there because i
remember he was having what was he
talking about before though i don't know
he was talking about like how like
like a host he respected or something
yeah and then and then he was suddenly
like dude it's like hitachi
what i remember getting like mental
whiplash like here in this conversation
and
where the [ __ ] did that come from and
then uh ordering a staff cross pizza
during recording oh yeah i think that is
like if you're technically speaking the
like strongest
i mean i guess like technically speaking
yes you're right that is like the
biggest tangent but we're not talking
about yeah we're not talking about
biggest tangent we're talking about best
tangent and i think hitachi sacrifice i
think is like it's like by far my
favorite tangent i don't think it'll win
for me it's either that or the eating
the extinct tortoises i think people
really enjoyed the tortoise bit yeah i
think that was a good bit that was a
good bit it's true i still want to eat
one
all right well like these are just like
random conversations i guess i just like
the itachi sacrifice just came out
nowhere and i hope that wins let's find
out all right yeah the best tangent as
voted by you the viewers was
i was right again boys i'm [ __ ] what
is this
oh i keep getting it right i know the
fans i know you why did you vote me as
big as clown no [ __ ] you all except when
he uh has
selective memories
i remember on the day
do you remember that was a fun tension
that was a fun tangent
i thought this was one of our like even
though i don't think the views reflected
it i think this is one of our like
strongest episodes yeah yeah i thought
we were just on point yeah yeah yeah
everyone had jokes yeah everyone just
came out swinging i think we had the
good discussion about the deserted
island in the city oh yeah yeah yeah and
the zombie apocalypse yeah
we were just like on point that was like
one of my favorite episodes i don't
think it got nominated for best episode
though but i think it was one of my
favorite ones yeah yeah
that one came in first with thirty one
point five percent of the vote okay oh
okay unlock it
that's a lot yeah in second place were
the turkish mafias i mean the taxi
drivers with 5 16.
okay yeah i think i was going to say
that was yeah i think the jan episode in
general was just like a really really
good i mean we were just like vibing
with jan and jan spews like the most
random [ __ ] all the time anyway that's
just that's just jan off camera yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly definitely all
right um you'll be happy to know that
third place was your stuffed crust pizza
with fourteen point two really okay
that's surprising actually yeah yeah
yeah i didn't think about that all right
next one though
lads best strip who had it
it's gone
who had the drippiest drip i mean i i
think i already know
all right let's find out what the
nominations are yeah connor's drip
jacket
i mean he bought it for that reason
why is god's clown costume and my banana
clown costume in here that's what i
don't know okay here's the thing here's
the thing i think the clown costume
actually looks good with that when i
wasn't wearing like the hats and the wig
like like like like i remember i
remember like i got a lot of comments be
like yo that doesn't actually look bad
it looks like really comfortable pjs it
was like really comfortable pj was not
like other clowns that said that oh damn
dude it was better than mine
and then uh chris and a hat
i have a feeling that's gonna be a
strong contender yeah uh cali's rapper
costume which is which is actual drip by
the way and then connor's titty aparri
merch i think cause i'm always wearing
yeah oh you're always wearing that yeah
even off-stream off trash taste i'm
always wearing yeah
i mean
it's basically just like winning because
haha meme you know
funny it's funny i laugh every time
people because people don't know connor
has three pieces of clothing the drip
jacket the aemia shirt and the tt motor
that's all he [ __ ] wears
[Applause]
he literally bought the drip just to
like win this award i know for a fact he
bought the trip to win this award and i
spent an absurd amount of money on a
jacket that i can't wear for most of the
months because it's way too [ __ ] hot
he paid to win the best trip yeah i
better win i better [ __ ] you you know
what i'm gonna be so happy when chris
wins this yeah i dude i i'm i'm praying
i'm praying come on baby
i bet him
chris wins ironically i leave the
christmas ironically because we're going
to get a new soldier's moment all right
let's find out then
the winner of the best trip according to
the trash taste fans come on come on
come on come on
chris in a hot
this is collusion
stop the count i want a recount i want a
recount
i'm calling out the reddit i saw they
were doing it i knew
so good man
you guys man you guys are awesome thank
you so much for calling out the reddit
they colluded to do that thank you so
much if this was an honest election i
would have [ __ ] won
did i at least come second
unfortunately you did [ __ ]
wait what were the percentages uh chris
won with 40.2 percent of the vote they
colluded came in second with 30.1
collusion
see you tried to pay to win corner but
i can't
you should know that doesn't work connor
we're not ea here we're trash taste just
because you're a whale doesn't mean you
have the best account all right we're a
podcast of the people connor we can't be
bought out by money
guys you guys are awesome guys you guys
are right oh yeah
thank you so much guys thank you so much
thank you so much good morning my fellow
weebs and gamers it's your boy josh the
mangalad here to let you know that this
episode of trash test is sponsored by
manscape watch out the skate box is
coming ah you asked for it and our
friends over at manscaped have listened
because they have brought back the ultra
smooth package get hype and just for you
guys you can get 20 off by using our
coupon code trash taste oh my lord well
let me tell you a little bit more about
the ultra smooth package just in case
you don't know the ultra smooth package
is a specialized grind shaving kit to
help you both protect and smooth your
most sensitive areas i'm talking crop
shaver razors i'm talking crop
exfoliator i'm talking crop gel men you
no longer have to borrow your ladies
stuff to shave down there all three of
these vegan cruelty free and sulfate
free products are included so you know
your manhood is in good hands and
without compromise so what are you
waiting for if you love these nuts just
as i do
then make sure to go to manscape.com and
use our coupon code trash taste to save
20 off your order that's 20 off with our
coupon code on screen links in the
description below thank you to manscape
for sponsoring this episode back to the
show these nuts oh well at least uh
hopefully i won't lose the next one yeah
all right so
the next award is lazier strip
their mom buys all of their clothes well
chris uh chris won this one last year
right yeah yeah
yeah let's see let's see what are the
nominations for this one i don't know
let's find out
so we got christmas
we got connor's monkey costume connor
trash taste hoodie i don't know about
that that is drip that's our merch uh
well i think it's because i wore it for
15 weeks in a row it was laziest
listen i was trying to represent the
merch so i wore it 15 weeks in a row all
right and then god me and then connor's
amy i love how half of these are called
yeah it was oh is my shirt lazy that is
iconic i whipped that out on a special
occasion
i mean the problem is here right as like
i of course i think out of here i think
chris is going to win yeah because
connor has three nominations for this
one sure because that's spread out
between three spread out between three
right i was gonna win because i saw
everyone online colluding to make sure
chris won
because because here's the thing connor
the the
the award is laziest drip right
uh your emmy's shirt has been nominated
two years in a row yeah i didn't lose
last year and i'm not going to lose
again
how is my monkey costume lazy drip
i mean it's barely closed
it's a costume how does god's clown
costume in best trip but my monkey
costume is in lazy strip oh yeah
how does that make any [ __ ] sense
[Laughter]
viewers the viewers have half a brain
cell i think
let's just find out i guess all right i
think we know who it's going to be
it's going to be is
to complete the circle christmas
hey
[Applause]
so like that's like a plus minus zero
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah someone
at all so he doesn't get on water too
yeah i'm sorry chris yeah oh my bad
shouldn't have worn that hat dude all
right well i guess next stop i love that
i i want him to wear it again i want him
i actually want a curious george monkey
that actually wears the exact same hat
really i want to give him a skateboard
like it's like like you know i want to
give him a skateboard so he can like
recreate the hello
children i would imagine i need to see
that yeah yeah right one chris please
please i'm begging i'm playing how much
did he win by 90 yeah yeah uh chris won
that with fifty point five percent of
them so
oh wow
who came second actually
uh connor's trash taste hoodie oh okay
thirty two points
in a row
15 years in a row that's a that's a good
quality hey you can work 15 weeks in a
row without washing it by the way yeah
yeah exactly that's just that's just the
testing
so
next stop is one that's near and dear to
all our hearts
the next
sorry i can't english
the next nomination is the best rant of
trash
we had a lot of those as well there's a
lot of okay here's the thing i'm not
sure what was nominated i can't remember
um but
what's the difference between a rant and
an argument right because i'm around
this when you go on probably on your own
yeah it's like a one-sided like
or like it's one long [ __ ] okay okay
all right let's see what the nominations
are that's rants uh goggle troll by
japanese yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this one
okay
we can't call anime mid anymore
i mean i mean yeah that was like a
collective rant yeah that was that was a
collective rad and joey you got the
brunt of it i got the sound of it
because i said the word apparently uh we
do not support nfc still standby
all right still stand by it uh ranting
about jumping with morick
was that a rant
what's the clip of this can we see the
clip of why this counts as a wrap yeah
what is junkie oh yeah yeah we should do
it together oh you've done it yeah
you've done it yeah i've got it i've got
to take a wild guess what you're doing
you jump up you can't
i would like to try streaming
don't get my hopes up
all right that's a run because no one
would answer my question of what was
jumping
and i asked like two times or something
i think yeah sure and then
but i have a feeling it's going to be
the we can't call anime made any
probably probably i just have a few i
want nfts to win because i can continue
ranting about nft the one time i want
nfts to win yeah
that's fine it's the one time i'm
supporting nft come on this is the one
time
well
do we have from there it's gone learns
the dead sea is a lake are you serious
okay okay okay
i mean i mean
i mean i was very salty at the moment i
feel like at least you got some
representation look at that [ __ ] side
eye you're giving to
that just tells the whole story right
there
he's fuming boys i mean i i feel like
this is probably the most it's pretty
close to this yeah the most emotional
rant definitely all the audio
percentages this is pretty close all
around uh won that with 28.5 percent of
the vote okay second place was him
getting trolled by a japanese bank with
21.9 percent of the vote oh no sorry
second was uh we can't call anime mid
anymore with 22 percent of them all so
about the same third was a japanese bank
uh and nfts came in fourth with 17.4
percent of the vote
fair enough damn all right all right all
right we definitely remember those rants
differently to the rest of the audience
what's up next joke yeah
i think that's ranting about nfts has
just like gone throughout because we've
done so many times we've done it so many
times yeah next one though oh this one's
also hot dear near and dear to our heart
best argument
so this time it's a two-sided rant yeah
essentially yeah that is technically an
opposing two-sided grant uh yeah we have
a lot of those which ones
oh my god uh how many arguments did we
have this year um a lot and we continue
doing so uh let's see what the
nominations are uh the great chicken
debate oh that was this year wasn't it
oh my god that feels like an eternity
that was in the studio holy yeah that
was like right when we moved i was like
the week after we moved in like i think
and we're just like can we top any of
the arguments season one and then we
immediately come in with like the great
chicken debate
i i want to clarify people to this day
still think i don't eat bone-in chicken
i do i just prefer boneless
killer clowns yeah still a clown yeah i
like i like boning chicken i just prefer
bone out i'm glad i'm sitting on this
side right
i'm glad i'm saying i hang out with
people who like watch trash taste
sometimes like i met them they'll be
like oh you sure you're okay eating that
bone bone and chicken like what the [ __ ]
yes i don't good [ __ ] i would just would
prefer if there was no bones exactly you
deserve that you deserved you both
deserve that you both shut up
i'm so curious just just see how we cut
this together boundless boneless i'm a
boneless kind of guy man i'm a boneless
get that get that bone out of there if i
can't eat it get it out of my face
sometimes i just don't want to go
through the process of being like a
[ __ ] animal and tearing this [ __ ]
from limb
you're like
do maternal
this is like one of the few times where
all three of us are talking at the same
time
i just i just realized how much of a
karen i sounded there because you are a
karen it tastes better
it tastes
better because it does i was just like
you guys have made me do something i've
never done before which is go for
carrots
i was like call the manager mailing get
here right now all right and then we
also have obviously the great pizza
debate yeah i mean this this is another
like two versus yeah argument
uh and then connor thinks he definitely
bought a neighbor oh okay so the last
two are from the the figure special
which they were certainly a lot of
crowning arguments on yeah yeah yeah and
then all among yourself
true
that was one of my favorite arguments
i just love how angry colin got yeah
i'm like you do realize you're fuming
over [ __ ] among us right now
i realized all of these arguments are
like me
having to argue
all of these are you being difficult i'm
not being difficult you're on my side
for this one were you talking about i
was in the middle [ __ ] no oh you
worked out like you bro what are you
italy in world war two
i was average i was average chicken
enjoyer right there i was like i can go
both brothers
i'm not letting you get away with that
jerry i am not late
because because let me off the hook
joey comes in because like this is this
isn't even even like in the worst food
takes right because it was so
overshadowed by the rest of the chicken
debate that i remember being like bone
and chicken the same and like joey was
like no all chicken is the same and it's
like that just like erupted like the
[ __ ] argument yeah and then he just
like stepped out he he stepped out i was
like
the same all right
thing the chicken one will win
the chicken i think the chicken one is
the most iconic definitely ah and
lasting impact and i'm still we're still
arguing it to this day like honestly
like great pizza debate i'm like
whatever connor can think what he thinks
like he's just like wrong you guys are
just wrong in the great chicken debate
like you guys are just wrong yeah
whatever whatever you just was just
wrong i'm sorry all right let's find out
then the best argument of joshua's 2022
is
the great chicken debate naturally
naturally
not even not even surprised by that i
shouldn't even be close that shouldn't
even be close it's not
[Music]
argument available uh at the end me and
connor were just like we were handshake
about both being clowns yeah and then we
were immediately afterwards go back into
arguing
it's like you shook hands and then it
was like i still hate you
you're
uh next up is
um so as you know with trash taste we
have a lot of food takes and we have a
lot of
bad food takes so the next award
is to reward our worst food takes i mean
to be honest i don't even have to see
the nominations i know who's on this i
know there's one there's all bread
tasters okay
okay i would just have to say that
obviously that was a bad food take but
there are there have been some
outrageous food takes this year well
let's let's see let's see what they're
gonna do it's like like we we
just look at that
we are truly living up to our names here
all right so cereal is better without
milk that's like okay i stopped by that
ninety percent of bread tastes the same
uh all rice tastes the same that's joey
that was just me miss phrasing what i
was trying to say
all japanese rice tastes the same i can
obviously tell the difference between
[ __ ] japanese rice and basmati rice
okay like i'm not that dead in the skunk
uh new york pizza is better than
thanksgiving
that's pretty [ __ ]
also your canned tuna tastes better than
fresh tuna that's nothing
like it's like you don't even know that
doesn't even deserve a clip man that
doesn't even deserve a clip
i i think it has a taste to it
that was so bad
and then chewy steak is like meat
flavored that was melon
yeah that just came out of nowhere i was
just like you said what
okay so there's two gaunt two connor one
me one mailing well i know who's gonna
win congratulations on your rewards yep
yeah i'm just saying to say right now
just say right now what is it the worst
food take is
new york pizza is nice [ __ ] bread
like i saw connor's jaw literally drop
for a second there
i was like no
all the europeans missed this one
that's for sure all right what how much
did it win by
uh
48.9 percent holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell i'm second and third out of
curiosity cereal is better without milk
came in second
congratulations on having the worst food
two doubles
that's the legitimacy i stand by that i
stand by that cereal is better without
the milk that was
chewy steak is like meat flavored gun
wow we weren't even in the we weren't
even in there
takes a good day hell yeah thanks guys i
don't believe it
thank you viewers
all right what's the next one connor
next up is you know you've heard the
worst food takes what about the best
poop man
two sides of the season
um we talk about poop a lot i don't know
how i don't know how i'm surprised we
have a category for this but apparently
we do what was that what was the tagline
you used to say for trash taste again
the podcast where we talk about food
anime and uh food poop and occasionally
anime yeah yeah
did i say that yeah that was you how did
you remember that i don't know because
it just stuck by me i'm like it's so
added it's true it's true so what are
the nominations yes uh oh yeah me
sniffing cat poop in a sock yeah that's
just me lean getting me there yeah yeah
we got have you ever coughed his [ __ ] at
the same time that's also me
that's like best out of context moment
as well
can we see can we can we see these clips
actually i want to see these guys yeah
yeah yeah yeah you have a very
suspicious sock
melon put cash [ __ ] in that sword
i couldn't [ __ ] believe it i couldn't
[ __ ] believe it i got paid
i got paid to sniff cat [ __ ] she brought
cat [ __ ] from her house to the office
yeah yeah yeah train
public transport that's what i was more
like offended about the fact that you
would do that yeah
joey
i don't even know why you said this have
you ever coughed and [ __ ] at the same
time no mine's fine
we're not talking about [ __ ] yet
yeah
[Laughter]
talks about pooping in video games this
is to do with ark i believe oh yeah yeah
yeah play this clip
really famous for pooping it really is
it's google arkansas why are you are you
sure arc is famous for pooping are you
trying to make it famous are you trying
to make your face google it right now
ark poop i've just seen compilations of
v tubers reacting to dinosaurs pooping
in ark and they just like lose their
mind what compilation yeah this was like
uh like a chef mac moment where we were
just like we did not like
tell her to talk start talking about
poop we tried our best to not talk about
poop because we had to guess this was
like they knew the assignment yeah yeah
yeah yeah right
uh and then we also have why god spends
30 minutes on the toilet you actually
genuinely take 30 minutes of [ __ ] we get
to the point in this office where i
legitimately go where's god yeah we go
and we realize he's been gone for 30
minutes did he go to the shops or
something no he's taking a [ __ ] are you
performing like alchemy in there like
why is it taking so long
i just don't feel satisfied until i'm
completely empty
i still stand by that man it's just like
you need once you go poop you need to
get it all out otherwise why are you
sitting down you know why are you saying
down i'm guessing this is the origin of
the poop i i guess now okay we found it
out let's play it so it's like this
right yeah right i'm like okay close the
lid flush and then i do this while it's
flashing but your pants are down right
no well then that's exactly the same
thing as i'm getting up i kind of like
pull it up
to the point of like like it's there but
i just got to zip it up and do the belt
you know you understand what i mean you
understand what i mean right no
why was this a conversation i i i
remember it was the day before we had
this episode i had this thing where the
guy
uh like flushed the toilet and then
immediately left the toilet and i
thought huh that guy must have done
everything and then flushed the toilet
and immediately walked out right now
because
i flush the toilet the moment i stand up
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i was
just like i wonder if i'm the same so i
guess that's why it came back oh yeah
yeah that was a pretty deep conversation
regarding poop because i remember we had
like like a 30 minute conversation just
breaking down poop technique i remember
like 15 minutes of talking about like do
you wipe from the front or from the back
well let's find out who the winner is oh
who do you want to win i want me
sniffing captain yeah yeah it's either
both of them are joey like have you
coughed and [ __ ] at the same time such a
[ __ ] good clipper
well the winner is
joey sniffs
you know i'll [ __ ] say that
i'm proud of that one well deserved well
deserved i did it for the boys thank you
very much melin
for possibly like i i think making the
most unintentionally memorable ad read
that we've ever done
because that wasn't ad read yeah it was
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm sure lavoy
was thrilled with one
what were the percentages
sorry
cat [ __ ] one with 39 percent of the vote
oh damn hell yeah and uh joey coughing
and [ __ ] one with 20 uh came in
second with 21.9 percent of them very
good
all right next category is oh this one's
a new one as well for this year this is
my favorite one the most privileged
moment oh
so you know you know i think the biggest
difference from like last year and this
year is that uh we have found out how
big a podcast could become we didn't
really
know that last year um so you know you
might have seen uh yeah what was the
conversation without where uh it was
like you've changed yeah right are you
changed right yeah this this this is
that award yeah so that you've changed
but you've changed the world nominations
though uh we got sysnap doesn't want to
be called positive strong
issues
i think i'm just like yeah because at
this point conor keeps calling me poor
and it's like honestly at any time i
could get something where i'm like
i'm not poor
[Music]
that's such a long in-joke explanation
sydney would hate it when i i used to
call her paul so i used to always call
her paul to piss her off
that's like that's like proceeds
very very long running thing where was i
you were in the toilet i guess oh i was
pooping okay okay okay
for 30 minutes yeah okay okay okay that
makes a lot of sense i was like what the
[ __ ] did this happen
i do not remember this
oh this one this one this one yeah they
go
yeah i'm i'm really sorry and i'm like
okay maybe we do need to get two rooms
and we're like yeah i'm really sorry
all the king-sized beds are gone this
one only has a queen-sized bed
this is a hotel i would stay in if i was
on holiday right we walk in
and there's a hallway that leads to our
bed right
and then so we walk in with me and
sydney look at each other and and i'm
just like
the gacha gods are on my side
i think what makes this even better is
just knowing like honestly just in the
position
like a peasant hotel yeah like i love it
i love it that's so good yeah yeah and
then i spent a thousand dollars on the
goku drip jacket i'm gonna do it again
i'd do it again very privileged
it's an iconic meme history piece oh got
it you got a steel cut you got a steal
there's only a thousand bucks a thousand
only a thousand bucks
only a thousand bucks wow
and then there's the boys going to
playing golf
is this privilege
is this privileged calling out every
golf player now what the [ __ ] no because
i recently got back into golf um and i
was like my god that is the most boomer
thing i've ever done see i don't i don't
think golf is a boomer thing you know i
i feel like it's a pretty much i don't
think it's a difference yeah it's a
movie thing so if you're broke you can't
be playing golf that's just facts
that's true okay okay yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah
we utter the word privilege yeah yeah i
guess that makes sense and there's conor
complains about his free card dude these
because this one wasn't even controversy
that was like started on the podcast
yeah it was controversy that was started
on twitter by kind of posting his like
image you had to be done right and then
the meals were crap right yeah so you
guys send me pictures of them oh yeah i
got i i posted one of them and i was
like this is the saddest breakfast ever
and it caused like a [ __ ]
argument
you almost got cancelled on twitter for
that didn't everyone's like people are
like man conor's privilege is acting up
so much
people acting like i [ __ ] went to
like eaten school and went to cambridge
because i said one meal was [ __ ]
they wanted to get the [ __ ] over
themselves
i hope that one would like to say cause
like
like just looking at that image i was
just like that's a very aesthetic image
that's good
if i'm going to the [ __ ] kids store
to get a playmobil set of fake food it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's all cold and hard it's
so bad it's just the way that like even
with like the worst meals they can serve
they still serve like really good
aesthetic-looking meals
i want that to win just like the
dichotomy of just gonna go like this
[ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] and i don't like the
picture you're looking pretty damn good
well let's find out there all right
let's find out the most privileged
moment of the trash days awards is
connor spent a thousand dollars on the
goku drip jacket i'll take that that's
the privilege i want that's the kind of
privilege i need around here
it was a bit more than a thousand
actually it was like a thousand yeah or
something
that is absolutely important i mean it's
all it's all privileged
who
who topped the charts for that top three
what's top three ooh all top three were
all pretty close um conor won that one
with 26.1 percent of the vote
uh sit snap came in second with 25.7
percent of the vote on sydney hold on
nearly privileged yeah and in third
place was god's quarantine hotel with
twenty two point one
i guess you can still call sydney poor
then because she's less privileged than
you connor
sydney you're poor this is the second
most frequently
[Laughter]
all right next up
next up
is
so we talk a lot of [ __ ]
on your trash taste this is the what
i've been waiting for we talk we talk a
lot of [ __ ] uh and we might not always
fact-check what we say
uh so this is the i made it the fuck-up
award
[Laughter]
where
where i'm glad that uh we're not part of
the scientific community where we have
to cite our sources
because 90 of the time we never have so
i'm glad people don't take this show
seriously yeah because my god yeah so
what are the nominations for this one
i'll just
all right starting off strong oh my god
all of these uh 2021 anime wasn't good
that was definitely like i made it the
[ __ ] out i'll admit to this one i
definitely made this the [ __ ] up that
came back to bite
yeah pretty much pretty much because
because i remember because like i don't
remember when you said this but i was i
because i was like i watched 2021 anime
i [ __ ] love 2021 anime so like when
this got spread around i was like did
joey say that i definitely would have
given him [ __ ] if he said that i was
surprised i think i remember still i was
surprised with the lack of [ __ ] i got on
the episode
you guys were kind of just like is that
right
that was it
and then we have uh from after dark
where fish don't exist that's still true
you can google it i just explained it
poorly yeah yeah that was just like a
poor explaining yeah
this one wasn't a poor explanation
i still
are you a doctor are you a doctor i
don't give a [ __ ] i would like to i
would like to know what i don't think
about this
well i'm definitely not a psychologist
because i thought introverts are
incapable of being social
which is just like i remember when like
jen said the most wild [ __ ] in this
episode yeah somehow they still got more
offended than joseph yeah
jen literally said like so many
misogynist comments and then this was
the one
john was just like so yeah here's the
entire dark world of the [ __ ] host
club world a lot of shady things going
on and they're like algebra on cape
aren't capable being social what the
[ __ ] pause the episode yeah that's right
draw the line i'm done because the thing
the thing that stands out about this is
that
out of all of these right i think this
was the only one where i like i like
corrected you for that one
yeah because i think i actually did
correct you yeah you're trying to
correct me to the best of your ability
but yeah yeah but you just like one
having it i remember i folded pretty
quickly on the introverts yeah i
realized what i said yeah but the 2021
one everyone was just like is that right
you know what it just says a lot about
me that as much as food poisoning isn't
an illness it's like an outrageous and
just i i like you talk to your doctor
it's just factually wrong you know like
you've turned you've turned the
factually the wrong thing into like just
like a feeling now yeah yeah yeah
i still got a cup of 20. i still think
it's 20
there's some other funny moments i
remember when i said that like pokemon
was the most googled thing in 1996 and
google didn't exist
i'm surprised i'm surprised
i think it's because we did like
you know when we were all like oh really
yeah i think that one wasn't brought up
because it was just you it was just an
out of context line yeah because it was
just like i remember hearing that and i
remember thinking that doesn't sound
right but my knowledge isn't good enough
to try and argue that fact am i crazy it
was the most google thing in one of the
years i can't remember which year it was
it wasn't 19 years
it was a shame she was like you had the
right meaning just [ __ ] up the
execution yeah exactly exactly because i
feel like a lot more lines that were
just passed over weren't nominated and i
got number of them i remember there has
been plenty of plenty of moments where
we've stopped recording and then we've
realized what we said the day after and
we were just like why did no one
challenge me on this and we were like
well we we didn't know either because
all of us are just like i guess you're
right he said it with such confidence
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right all right
what's the uh what's the winner of this
one you know what i i hope i win this
one with the i made it the [ __ ] up award
goes to
2021 anime wasn't any good
you know what i can't even defend myself
on that because i didn't watch anything
in 2021 bro
he literally made it i made it [ __ ] up
that was the most i made it that was
good i definitely made it the [ __ ] yeah
well all the percentages though wasn't
even close forty six point nine percent
forty seven forty six point nine percent
what is six point nine percent or a
second uh conor's food poisoning came in
at i thought that was gonna be strong
conditions second with 29 points with 29
oh my god oh sorry not sorry i guess
all right all right well next up
the best trash taste after dark episode
oh we're getting to the big awards well
you know obviously this year we really
like put our foot into after dark yeah i
think i know what's going to win this
because yeah yeah the nominations all
right let's see
i still love that yeah the one we try
american snacks
the one we rate beers yeah the one the
figure special uh the uh fifth grader
yeah yeah yeah
uh the uno one which is very popular
yeah the role playing one amazing stream
yeah yeah of course the charity stream
yes all of these are such great episodes
though yes i mean i i think it's obvious
which one's gonna win uh hey i mean yes
i think it's gonna be a 24-hour
challenge i think i think i would bet my
entire life savings on that this is
gonna win yeah really yeah but like
i don't know they're like all good but
for like different reasons i mean
obviously
this is five episodes in one yeah
you know this is like yeah yeah we raise
money
we did it we did a good thing that is
true you know we weren't just like i
guess of course it's like also the
recency bias as well right yeah i just
think it was a really big and also there
were just so many [ __ ] amazing
moments from these we got all of the
best out of context clips and out of
context i think it's like i would i
would be interested to see what do you
think would come second
i personally really like the trpg that
was like one of the funnest ttr uh that
was one of the finest trash takes after
dark so yeah i had to film as well
like everyone was on point like yeah you
know karen was like top of the game yeah
yeah every everyone was hilarious it was
so great because it was just so on point
to con asuba as well yeah like it was
literally like i watched it back i'm
like yeah damn we just made a con of
super episode just like live and i'm
just like how do we do this unscripted i
also named my character after the mom
from the hentai masterpiece and no one
noticed yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right
yeah yeah yeah um but like i yeah like i
mean a quick word about after dark i
would have to say like i think even like
there's a point where i think if you
don't watch after dark i actually think
some of our best content out this year
came from after dark you know uh i think
because i think initially we didn't have
after dark until the second half of the
year and a lot of efforts a lot of our
time and effort was put into making
after dark the best that it could be you
know you could argue sometimes like we
we
focus on that more on like the main show
at times because that's how like that's
how much we wanted it to get off the
ground um so you know if you don't watch
after dark please watch the vods there
are a lot of great moments and some of
the best moments of this year are in
after dark absolutely absolutely but uh
there can only be one winner though
let's find out
24 hour stream oh of course hold on
okay very nice
up
what is up
i mean i it still blows my mind how much
was raised that day
i remember because i i remember thinking
we set the goal at 100k and like about
five hours in i was like we've made a
massive mistake yeah we're not gonna hit
it
yeah yeah so yeah what was the
percentage breakdown of that oh forty
nine point seven percent yeah went to
the 2400 charity stream yeah um second
place was the trpg stream yep okay
yeah all right that makes so much sense
yeah totally got that right yeah all
right what's uh the next category jerry
all right well third to last
uh we have oh okay this one
as well is a new one and is i think
mostly after dark related but we've done
a lot of quizzes
oh
okay and we've had some pretty [ __ ]
monkey moments so that's the dumbest
quiz answer
so yeah we've uh had a lot of
oh i guess dumb answers on the quizzes
yeah this is quizzes i was either like
insane or just boosted yeah yeah never
in between on the quizzes yeah this is i
mean like the quiz this is like a new
category for this year right so we
wanted some representation for some of
the new content that we started making
this year i'm representation so i think
we should show these moments because i
think a lot of people wouldn't have seen
these moments because they didn't watch
after dark yeah so let's go let's check
out the next let's check out the
nominations
well obviously uh we got a connor spells
nor
uh play the clip actually
[Laughter]
say that again n-g-h-a-w norm
my moment of silence says it all i think
it was just like the because it was like
a moment aside and after he said that
and it was just like everyone in the
room was just processing what he said
like could you repeat that
not my proudest moment
you didn't even you couldn't even hold
in your laughter you're just like
could you feel that
i thought i thought you were joking at
first i was like no that was a mistake
right
it was just like the extreme confidence
i said it was like oh
yeah yeah i just for some reason i had
the blinders on i was so convinced
that's how you spelled it
come on for the life of me explain why
and then we obviously have uh the boys
give budweiser
we've already seen that one yeah uh the
baby one time
uh that was from the music quiz yeah
yeah yeah play the clip i thought baby
and one more time but i put stuff before
sure
not to mention you wrote baby one time
maybe one time i'm sorry but god is
getting a point i deserve it no he
doesn't get a boyfriend he said baby one
time
nice all right i will say i will say i
got [ __ ] over in this quiz by the way
because
it was the staff that said to me the
song name was hit me baby one more time
the official name is baby one more time
i was just too [ __ ] monkey to spend
it out properly okay maybe once but even
if i put the right the right name i
would still wouldn't have got the point
draws a house in the kanji question oh i
don't remember this one the next kanji
is house
i think i've got this all right show it
off all right
if you see this you know what it means
just be house right just re-house every
everyone knew what i meant everyone knew
what i meant and then the last one is uh
this one the uh
oh this one the meme quiz right no no
this is from the game oh the gaming quiz
yeah yeah yeah that's right which video
game did the meme press f to play
respects come from my [ __ ] call of
duty knowledge is [ __ ] awful oh it's
call of duty
you didn't know that
i said counter-strike source
[Laughter]
see okay this clip uh there's one issue
with trash taste after dark which is
like everything is live so we can't edit
afterwards yeah i remember seeing joey's
face of panic when i said oh it's called
a dude guys and jerry she goes
yeah i was like
because that wasn't caught on camera
because the camera was on me but joey
had just had like the biggest face of
panic and it was like so funny
just because it is an iconic moment
uh nora is my personal favorite but no
no it's my personal favorite
i really do i kind of don't want
budweiser to win because i don't want to
relive that moment anymore me would love
to see the after pay respect yeah
quiz answer of trashes after dark is
connor spells no
[Laughter]
well you know what well deserved
honestly that was well deserved as well
i will never let you
was it at least close
it was really close oh really okay that
one with 26.9 of the vote right uh
joey's pay have to pay respects uh press
f to pay respects came in second with 26
percent oh wow
less than a percent oh i'm sad but i
mean i deserve it that was very very
dumb and i have no recourse for it yeah
that was just that's what it was at
least it was funny at least it was a
good moment
you made a good moment you went a good
moment all right second and last one and
uh the second last moment is i guess
just moment of the year moment of the
year a single moment there are many
moments of this year it's just like one
i guess it's like one single snapshot of
the year there's many ma like there's
many great moments we've gone through a
lot of them already uh i think a lot of
them like are too long to be considered
a moment yeah they're very iconic pieces
but here are the moments that you guys
voted for
so it's
quantum mumbles the charity stream
announcements wait play and play that
one play the clip gary i think the five
dollars i don't think for the twenty
dollars none of us think that two
hundred fifty dollars i'm the main
protagonist i think with the ten dollars
thirty one gonna need to watch kintam i
look at the five dollars cherries do you
think of the ten dollars forty two jesse
swore i think of the twenty dollars oh
thank you the five dollars whispering i
think the five dollars no i think it's
ten dollars but okay one one seven thank
you for the ten dollars these not saving
the twenty dollars all right there we've
seen this one already uh they moved
among us
play that one
oh no oh no let me let me check this
tissue on the side first
why is it lubed who lubed this
is this like a lubed among us thing
it feels like a manga
i think if if we had like a court of the
year yeah that would definitely lead to
money is that a lubed among us
honestly like nothing else like
what surprised me is like even looking
back i'm like how did i how was i so
sure about that but it was like the only
thing that came to my mind as i was
touching it i was like it's lubed among
us because i remember i was like no
other guesses it's lubed among us
oh my god and then obviously me smelling
cat food yeah so we've seen that one uh
god decides to rob a 12 year old
yeah that kid's like 12. what's stopping
us
from
oh
what if uh mira distracts the shopkeep
by talking and then you you i go in and
nick though you go grab some potions
whatever you can how about that just one
no no murder no murder needed i love i
love that title out of context yeah that
was just that was just a great scene in
general if you're not into tt rpgs nor
was i but i've really had a lot of fun
filming that yeah and if you don't know
the context uh we that the gang decides
to rob a 12 year old
uh merchant naturally it's one day well
just like we tried to rob joey tried to
murder him yeah let's just kill him
let's kill him
and god spells quintessential quint
essential oh [ __ ] if i have to essential
q u i
n t yeah e s s
e m
t
[Music]
[Laughter]
i literally just got reminded of that
i've realized all of these best moments
are from after dark yeah i noticed that
as well why is that not part of like the
dumbest answers
what's the last one the answer is
shagging sheep what's this one in 1881
parliament passed legislation banning
what in wales shagging sheep
uh the answer is shagging sheep
not got no no i'm kidding
[Laughter]
oh my god i've never i've never had like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] boner taken out of me
yeah yeah that was a that was a [ __ ]
debated moment yeah i mean like i'm
surprised a lot of these moments i guess
because they're like short moments yeah
and they work the best in like a live
stream setting because these are all
amazing [ __ ] i feel that's what trash
tastes after dark is though it's just a
collection of like short bursts of music
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right chill as
well i think we don't really like
discuss much we just kind of have a fun
time yeah yeah yeah exactly
that's why fun games
all right well uh
what's the other thing is the moment of
the year this one i actually don't know
i don't know that's they're all like
fantastic moments budweiser it's gotta
wait i feel it's bothering it's gonna
win some come on give it to budweiser
the moment of the year goes to
beer tasting budweiser reveal
[Applause]
now that was an iconic moment i mean
considering how much this was nominated
in this i think this was like the most
nominated
like all the american viewers came
together and was like we got to nominate
for this one i mean even like the
non-american viewers came together
it was a great moment considering how
much we clowned on america it was the
trash taste instant karma
well what was the top three ashley yeah
uh top was budweiser review with 29.5
percent of the vote okay in second place
was lubed among us with 24.7 percent of
the vote thank god
so happy there is a god uh slightly
behind was robbing a twelve year old
with fourteen point three i robbed the
twelve we all did that we all did it's
your idea guys we did it was your idea
it's your idea to
[Music]
deciding which kids to rob
we're going to read the final award
what's the final award connor yeah of
course it's got to be the best trash
tasty episode of the year according to
you the viewers 50 whole episodes to
choose yeah i i i don't know what it
would be so let's have a look
yeah episode 56 on with chris i've seen
65 that we can stop arguing that was a
food one that that was the chicken that
was the chicken debate one i believe
oh yeah i think this is the chicken
debatable that's the chicken debate yeah
yeah yeah yeah with jan yeah yeah figure
special which came right after it of
course and then we also have uh our
worst food taste this is the one where i
got gone to eat the stuffed crust yeah
yeah that's right uh that was that was
also the bread episode yeah oh okay uh
and then the only special we had this
year so far
and uh and then we had we almost died
which is i think the camping special
right yes yeah and then oh
yeah
the camping episode yeah the camping and
then uh the dream episode
lucid
[Music]
the cooking special is is special
because it's a special yeah
thank you very much for that joey what
what defines special joey look up i saw
us real quick
what won the best episode last year
i don't want to boost chris's ego sure
yeah he'll not shut the [ __ ] up he wins
yeah and you guys think we're joking i
honestly personally would probably vote
for the dream episode okay so it's it's
weird because like i think one of my
favorite to film was the dream episode
because that was a conversation i had
with the boys that i've kind of like
never had with anyone before yeah it was
just like such a weird conversation and
i it was like such like such a
self-discovery and such a discovery of
like oh
no everyone dreams the same way i do i'm
like what's going on that was like so
weird definitely um aside from that
obviously the great chicken debate was
very very funny
yeah
yeah
i mean the uh the argument on the figure
special i mean there's a lot of content
was great honestly these are all [ __ ]
fantastic episodes
yeah and uh obviously the way we chose
these you guys basically said which ones
are your favorites yeah yeah we decided
and then we opened voting
um so yeah i guess um
let's just see what it is all right
let's all right
let's wrap it up all right
the
best trash taste episode according to
you guys from the last year or 50
episodes or however the [ __ ] long
it's been 2022 yeah
is
the anime figure special oh
okay i wasn't expecting that
i mean that was a very good episode it's
a very good one holy [ __ ] because i
forgot this wasn't just the episode this
was just like the build up the mcu yeah
yeah yeah this was the tt mcu basically
um that yeah that was so fun to film as
well i've like what i'm proud of this
for is that our individual like if you
compare our individual videos to last
year
you could tell that we leveled up oh
absolutely you know what i mean and that
was that was obvious where we like all
of all of our videos like doubled in
length hasn't it yeah definitely
definitely and also not to mention this
year we also had the after dark one as
well right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's a lot to keep up
with i think it was like nine hours of
footage all together it was a lot out of
the five videos thank
carrying
you
very
why i think almost all of them are
really good you know i think uh yeah all
the arguments aside it was a fan
favorite i mean clearly i mean uh yeah
yeah we had a lot of fun doing it uh
blood pressure was rising but i think
i i understand why it was voted yeah
what was the result top three what are
the top three top three uh first place
uh was the figure episode with 22.3
percent of the vote wow second place was
100 ways to die in japan with chris
broad oh
thank god 20.3 of the vote and in third
place was
the cooking special with 17.9 percent
nice nice nice nice
good to know people still like the
special oh yeah thank god thank you
thank god thank you very much
yeah well i guess that's kind of like
that's kind of it
season two of trash tastes i guess right
until like damn how do you how do you
guys feel season two when compared to
like season one i mean yeah absolutely
was great
i mean you know it was it was okay right
i'm not gonna say it wasn't me but i
think you know we could have done more
specials but yeah it was a nightmare
with moving and getting everything all
set up to be fair and trying to get
after dark all done yeah yeah i was
about to say like to be fair you know i
think because of the fact that we've
really put our strengths into after dark
this year like yeah i feel that kind of
led us away from the specials a little
bit yeah you know i'm still very proud
of off the dock you know people loving
it yeah um sure you couldn't get more
guests on really i would like to have a
few more guests definitely just like
three or four more guests to mix it up
and uh it was just kind of unfortunate
where we couldn't really find anyone and
write timings and we did find people
yeah it was kind of like and then we had
to bulk record it was kind of old i mean
we definitely thought the borders were
going to open by the second season right
yeah but uh unfortunately yeah i mean i
think we definitely like i think one
thing i would always say about trash
days is we always try to do something
new and something different and i would
say like season two is definitely
different from season one absolutely um
and it might not have been reflected in
the main channel but it was definitely
reflected with like everything we did
outside of the main channel oh yeah
because it wasn't just like the studio
move it was just we've really tried to
we always try to give you the best
content even if it's all not not all put
into one place i think the proudest
thing that i did this year was
definitely like the 24 hour stream yeah
absolutely
like one thing one massive massive
massive difference from season one and
season two uh is our team behind the
cameras yeah because season one we had
malin and we had ashley uh and that you
know that was that's all we had and then
we couldn't have done everything that we
did in season two especially something
like the 24-hour stream yeah without the
massive dark shows
yeah all the other shows because the
thing is like
i would love to do more after dark but
logistically it's just so much harder
than main channel videos right
definitely because because like with the
main channel videos we can record that
ahead of time you know we can record
whenever we want also a lot more
planning goes into after dark yeah like
the regular episodes yeah yeah we just
like sit down and talk here you know
like we have to have people like write
quizzes plan what we're going to do we
have to schedule stuff there's a lot
more work that goes into after dark and
we really hope you guys have enjoyed
after dark yeah um it will return when
we're back from traveling around and you
know
but in the meantime like hey subscribe
to the channel yeah watch all the after
dark stuff there's plenty of good yeah
no one subscribes to after dark yeah
people watching people watch after that
but no one's subscribed yeah yeah
yeah um what is there anything you guys
are looking forward to in the season
three would you what do you guys want
out of them next year i think we'll have
more guests than we've ever had yeah i
think so i think uh you know they were
going to have more specials than this
year yeah
i know for sure that we're going to have
more yes because we already have uh
plans
yeah you'll get more specials and
hopefully we can just uh make it all
better yeah like we will continue
endeavoring to like push the envelope
with not just being a podcast channel uh
but just being a show but just being a
show do we all we want to do is like
make good content and we hope you guys
can see that whether that's on like the
main channel or anything else we choose
to do
um we're always going to be trying to
push the envelope to do trying to do
something new and one thing without
spoiling anything that we do or anything
that's coming up um we're definitely
going to be using more budget in season
three hell yeah let's go
like a lot more buzzfeed things are
coming yeah yeah yeah
so don't think that you've you've
reached the end of trash taste we have a
lot a lot of excitement
baby this is it's always just the
beginning okay 100 episodes yeah yeah
yeah yeah 100 more to go so yeah yeah i
guess like thank you to you guys
like it's i didn't think that we would
get two hundred episodes i think we've
all been blown away by just like the
insane amount of support that everyone's
been sticking around yeah yeah i think
uh 100 episodes a lot to ask yeah you
know
it's a lot for our podcast as well right
but it's uh yeah i think uh reading the
reddit seeing the tweets people just
saying you know how much trash taste
means to them i think uh that that
really reinforces why we're doing this
and yeah why we enjoy doing it other
than the bank of course
but i really do appreciate it i think we
all really really appreciate the support
and how much trash taste means to some
of you guys
we hope we can make more memes more
moments and uh more memorable bits for
you guys to
just have fun with yeah just shout out
to the fans shout out to the redditors
shout out to the staff and shout out to
the boys yeah that's that's all thank
exactly unfortunately all the staff here
today but otherwise i would like to get
them more to come on camera because we
have like a pretty massive crew right
now a lot
yes um
but yeah i guess that's that's kind of
it right that's it
we'll see you guys
episode 101 i guess
yeah start over but hey in the meantime
though look at these lovely pages look
at these lovely patrons these guys are
the goats right here they are supporting
the show and uh hey if you'd like to
support the show hopefully the next
hundred episodes and more of trash days
then uh follow us on patreon patreon.com
also follow us on twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our face listen to us on spotify
but yeah
yeah see you guys in season three is it
again
is that what we're calling it i don't
know see you guys for another 50
episodes for and we'll be celebrating it
all the same in the trash taste awards
part three i guess yeah see that we'll
see you then bye
[Music]
you